l'amateur de
l'homme nous saluer vincent lelong
scream brasse toutes manières il a lieu
il a eu la fièvre cette nuit d'où qu'il
est pas forcément
des hallucinations tu l'accord lui par
de bas
alors on espère que vous êtes avec nous
pour cette rolls du data de piles
on a vu hier que magnus carlsen avait
repris les commandes en solitaire c'est
sa victoire contre eux mêmes et est
aujourd'hui ce nouveau village et blancs
les noirs par d'autres contrecarrer la
chine ouais donc je pense qu'on va
s'attendre à une partie assez rapide
je pense pas que car akin
vraiment prennent des risques pour aller
chercher 4ème carte ça ne va peut être
essayer un petit peu un mais martial
idée en tête d'aller noir mais qui
n'aurait pas participé en vidéo i n'est
pas surtout il est dans une situation il
n'a pas besoin de prendre de risque
excessive moi je sens le monde pour
drogués ouais je pense que la formule
assez rapide dans cette partie car avec
une quarantaine
dont on va voir ouais on avoir suite on
abat son premier poursuivant guy qui a
gagné quatre parties d'affilée
avec un fort bel val rappel mais contre
goody
donc je suis partie intéressante parce
que bon kirill est en forme
et il a lancé j'ai vu hier à dans son
interview qu'il était un peu comment
votre bon vieux temps j'ajoute fait ses
courses avec 47
donc je pense qu'il a envie d'essayer le
quesnoy parce qu'à part d'affilée je
pense que là il est il est un petit peu
en brèche
bah il ait un rush met en confiance et
du coup il a glané blanco duda honda
c'est un super joueur mais pas forcément
3 way il a un manque de réussite donc
soit de la partie avantageuse qu'il
n'arrive pas
à gagner donc on va voir un peu ce qui
se passe par ici mais je pense que c'est
une partie qui va être animée
choc du jour a prévu que hier il a gagné
rejoint tout petit bras votre jean
claude jean claude dissaux voyageurs
dans une finale l heure pas très drôle à
cannes approche aujourd'hui j'ai choisi
le fait cessionnaire lambda et dacquois
tôt aujourd'hui on a un chien comme un
média robe deux paires lors de la ronde
d'hier
bon ben on va voir ce qui se passe un
bon média bien sûr à recoller au groupe
l'angoissé de gagner je pense qu'on a il
ajoute pour en tout cas échant clan ben
certains qui quand même pas facile pour
lui donc peut-être qu'il va essayer de
neutraliser
maintenat mais
en quelques secondes et ims avec un sale
jeu de réflexion qui est invaincu dans
tous les autres ont moins peur d'une
partie
audio ya pas d groupe 47
et je crois bien que tu as raison
mais c'est sûr ces
visites contre ton type foule avec un
appel fargues et qui ramenait à trois
défaites d'affilée dans le duel 100 par
100 indiens duel indien alors jam e jam
et je lui en fin j'avais déjà vu
plusieurs fois prague bad j'ai dit ok
voilà après je vous simple je peux pas
te dire quel tournoi c'était quelle
cadence s'était
peut-être cette double x sur un piteux
dire mais en tout cas je sais que prague
avait déjà battu plusieurs fois et du
coup bon pour le moral c'est pas mal un
carré noir il dit va prendre sa chance
pour essayer de bas de l'année blanche
aujourd'hui
dans le haut du tableau
il va t'on pouey ouais donc donc voilà
on va voir un peu mais je pense à une
partie qui bat qui va être animée c'est
clair les joueurs indiens par indien
kung fu en fait prendre la partie sont
pas copains
vivant voilà il se bat là pour gagner
donc ils vont jouer et bail peut se
passer n'importe quoi
sérieux arnaud pour le soja coton va
croiser les doigts pour que la connexion
des stocks tiennent le coup ici
et on a 40 ans rapporte qui est
peut-être la partie
alors caruana rapport donc à ronel afin
de remonter dans le tournoi de suite
après sa grosse gars contre qui
il va bien réagi et là les blancs
rapport à park est bien placé aussi donc
je pense que le deux jours on voit à
coeur d'essayer de
deux commandants de cette partie donc je
pense une partie animée en fait toutes
les parties je pense
risquent d'être animés 1 sauf pour moi
je pense à mon sens à partir de carl
scène car yaqing qui va se solder pour
l'annuler rapidement jamais même
série dario du coup je vais finir cette
petite présentation pendant ce temps
salut néandertal au passage de la venue
à toi tu pars tu vas bien on a tout va
qu'il y aura les peut-être blanche
contre grand des lieux de grande vitesse
car au fond du trou dans ce tournoi
c'est la cible est double up je crois
qu'il est toujours à la recherche de sa
première victoire
c'est un petit peu lui aussi il a la
classe blanche l'a clairement clairement
tenté aujourd'hui
et enfin on a échappé aux contrôles en
forest
deux des jeunes noirs de ce tournoi ne
fermera pas lequel tenant du titre
surprise qui après avoir fait un début
de tournoi
on you you dont la victoire est de fait
un petit peu solidifier son jeu il a sur
deux nuls et cp au cambodge en lui pour
le coup très solide qui perd peu de
parties il a une défaite pour l'instant
une victoire
après six penco jeu il a eu beaucoup de
réussite pas souvent je veux un résultat
réussi pas ce bâtiment mais surtout la
position
parce qu'il a eu beaucoup de positions
quand même inférieur voire très proche
de la défaite et il a réussi à trouver
des ressources incroyables partout
notamment même univers
donc donc web il est solide dans ses
résultats mais dans les partis
ben il se bat énormément et mega qu on
se trouve dans les ouvertures après
c'est un jeune joueur donc son
répertoire ivg l'infini donc ça explique
que si cela ils ont pensé justement par
la combativité
la can a d'ailleurs
tiré mais
ouais je crois qu'il y ait une durée
d'une année je pense qu'il a 19 ans il
je pense richard cutter est ce quelqu'un
peut nous donner l'info mais voit ce que
je ferai c'est un petit peu plus il doit
avoir 20 ans
je pense qu'il a permis de parer super
qu
il est né en 2002
il va sur ses 20 ans et qu'on les
appelle un vote fort est jordan
je marque pour être si noir que la
matrice de grossesse
après les fortins pour son âge elle a 14
ans elle a deux mille deux cents lots
mais bon lula 2007 soit quand même
donc il est né en 99 voilà vingt trois
ans 22 23 hockey et salue post-apo
douala j'ai bien dit le penalty sans
gardien quoi
pour toi
il aller plus haut
aubiac position de shoot je te propose
pour venir en dessous on va juste
conclure sa petite présentation avec
quand même notre notre frenchie prodige
corse marc andrieu nommé d'ici qui
aujourd'hui à les noirs contre le joueur
néerlandais winy non gelée mal doit voir
moeurs dame ouais c'est ça voilà qui est
d'ordre est une business tôt ouais il
est il est bas il travaille beaucoup il
est jeune il a pris 100 points en un an
et
moi j'ai trouvé au moins très
impressionnant quand je les ai vus au
portugal
franchement très forte bon en tout cas
marc andrieu qui a signé pour ceux qui
n'ont pas vu hier une superbe victoire
il a ma tête mon adversaire sur
l'échiquier joël mat avec tours fou
cavaliere donc n'hésitez pas les yeux
tardé à la partie si vous ne l'avez pas
vu
je te propose donc de commencer comme
promis ce
premier tour des stades d ouverture avec
avec champion de contrebande à ce qu'il
ya déjà eu onze coups de fouet en
quelques minutes et on voit des
policiers des pions très avancé donc ma
mère c'était la sortie du tournoi qui si
on voit équipondéré avec les deux
couleurs ouais alors sais pas c'est quoi
du coup
jusqu'ici
tout va bien
català ouais
il a encore encaissé le pion aux autres
c'était personne n'avait pas jugé
incroyable ouais les noirs mamediarov
il avait déjà montré une idée
intéressante avec une madame deux tours
et la paramount a envoyé son pion belle
on va voir ce qui s'est passé mais
ça c'était déjà qu'un 4 qu'un set mais
n'y avait pas eu ce symptôme cateau jeu
non ça me dit rien si je suis certaine
opposition dans les commentaires le dire
ça dans 2
0 c'est ça la position prêtée à
l'important c'est la même position
exactement élus donc là il ya eu à trois
parties de cartes neri petit remplir
ouest petit rock il n'avait pas forcé ok
donc je suis encore d'avariés
certains croient que trois parties
et là il a joué à troyes
il n'a même pas pris le temps d'enlever
cet au delà des
cavaliers ou 5 bat on aurait ce contrat
si c'est possible si c'est quand même
sur la diagonale du fou et puis en club
cela casse et si ce qui est important et
le plancher d'après défendre ils ont
peut-être après il y aura même des
dingues k4 quand même va faiblir le
le pion au lundi 4 mai
il y avait même une idée alors peut-être
que la paire de tours à six thématiques
aussi dans les positions de de catalan
même d'anglais sein des capitaux et du
800 m dames condé 4 donc avoir hérité
systématique aussi un fou prend 1 à 8 et
d'un prend au sein de cette thématique
bon ben j'ai je le centre j'ai plein de
choses
ouais vraiment ça c'est intéressant mais
je sais pas si c'est le bout ici mais en
tout cas ça d'autres choses existant ok
donc cavalier s'en extraie prématuré
pour pouvoir pas forcément
mais c'est ma maison avec les blancs
dans les premières hauteurs de
l'impression qu'ils voulaient envoyer un
chèque à tous les jours et maintenant
avec les doigts il ferait payer 2,5 tous
les jours comme si je faisais des petits
paris avec lui-même où je sais pas avec
des potes c'est comme quand tu dois qu'à
leurs mots dans une conversation
aujourd'hui passent à la télé tu dois
qu'à leurs mots lui c'est sur sa partie
d'échecs à jouer
probable ces petits délires mais c'est
bien du spectacle
il des 3
x 8 min
ces lois donc une réaction typique
donc la c3 assaisonner
passe quand m ok tu prend b3 ben dame
prend b3 et ce avec des pions noirs sont
quand même assez faible surface blanche
est donc là il décide de rendre le pion
sans ouvrir les lignes et on peut jouer
toujours accessit tout ça mais bon ça
paraît quand même assez artificiel donc
la b4 n'est pas possible un appel aux
deux vis-à-vis entre les deux tours
ainsi
si je récupère il est sûr d'y parvenir
ouais donc du coup est rompu il
développe
il conteste la grande des galas c'est
logique est aussi important et défendre
un tour à 8 ans ouais parce que et par
rapport à ce qu'il a fait après b4
et bien s'il y avait quatre prises
prises le coup de sang à toi
ouais ok
qui va sur ses 5 ans moi je m'entendrai
cavaliers 1,4 ça a l'air compliqué
possibilités ça fait quand même un
peut-être
ouest ils ont appréhendé 20h44
touristique
que mme alliot 4 on peut chez cavale et
c5 été compliqué peut-être comme
cavalier d2
approfondie vis-à-vis 1 / sur les fous
alors en attendant
dam des trois plus qu'à valider en tout
cas se faire clouer le cavalier c'est
plus agréable
donc
tu contrôles à gaz
surtout par ce prix là je vais déroger
ce serait problématique
gardiens l'arrivée dans ça fait pas même
s'il a eu 9 44 a répondu on rappelle que
les joueurs commencent à partir 1h40 fan
park où donc ça veut dire qu'ici il en
pleine récitation de s'échanger langue
qui rêvent de chez un petit peu sachant
qu il laissera bien de faire pareil en
russie donc oui ou non je sais pas s'ils
s'y connaît un peu cette position aussi
l'a surpris encore une fois je checke
juste ma base on dîne par l'outil de
chasse car on voit que yao que le parti
dans cette position si d'ici là sûrement
peut-être déjà été joués 1 mais ça donne
quand même une bonne indication que
c'est une variante rare mais c'est vrai
que je parle plus ou moins trop le
souvenir de voix c'est de voir cd5
bekkat sur ce par cette espèce de
catalan le candidat ben
ouais
beaucoup d'idées dans ce tournoi proposé
par un métier rare dans les ouvertures
là bas il essaie vraiment de le créer
les choses en jacques partie le sac
qu'on aime chez lui lorsque genre qu'on
créatif et qui avec les trous des idées
que charge des idées pour essayer de
déstabiliser un petit peu l'adversaire
de changer un petit peu de sorties
toujours exactement la même chose
par exemple à la parcelle bon pendant
qu'on priant
alors quoi
trouver une répétition
non je pense même pas traversé
ouais ok relief 5
ouais ça c'est
oui ou non mais bon je des 5
km et des cinq des quatre puisque c'est
un peu commune c'est un peu comme une
commune française de chance les hauts
lieux de la structure
est passé grand chose
symétriquement rupture de déséquilibre
bon après il ya des idées quand même 15
jamais mais
c'est plus sur les intentions des
joueurs en fait si les blancs ils sont
là et bouche tordue ferniot la
wii mon cas car akin cela ne l'atteindra
pas et vu son choix d'ouverture ben je
pense que carey qui ne va s'y rend il
voulait essayer de pousser un peu il
aurait pas cette position a trié autre
chose et non comme on l'avait dit un
cagnard il a une grosse partie contre
prague il a fini état et du coup belge
aux personnes 1 kg et blanc on pense
qu'il va pas se prendre la tête et bat
exception d'une rapide les papiers
seront opposés pour la suite c'est ça le
mois comme ça puis je dois être
satisfait laguiller deux parties même
d'amérique latine après trouver du
tournoi était vraiment insipide il a
quand même montré de belles choses
et comme jadis était parti
il a dû puiser dans ses ressources
ils ont gardé
par des 4
3 alors que la petit robe des quatre des
cinq jeux comme ça je changeais par
exemple
manger d'abord le 5
mai
qu'elle allait prendre prendre des cinq
des quatre fous dit sceptique ou des six
voix la caméra car scène qu'est revenu
saas et les positions qui ont été joués
quand je jouais énormément de fois
d'ailleurs la finale c'est la peau de la
pollution qui avec du chocolat du monde
de
deux
rapides je me trompe pas entre caruana
aîné paul adam les rondes est revenu le
temps jouer parce que
c'était
connaissez pas le règlement
howell matic parce que
c'est bien flou ça me paraît bien qu'il
avoue qu'il joue des six l'ours
passéiste et le groupe à
où d'habitude mais généralement c'est
qu'on leur retire en dessin qui fut
décisif comme ça
tant sur la tour à puteaux avec le pense
ouais elle a du coup le fait de jouer
des six après petit rock là il va
peut-être pas forcément j'ai les cinq
essais
ouais mais du coup c'est en deux temps
mais peut-être un problème par rapport à
des cinq d'avant vente est le tueur
mais trois dames et trois l'air
intéressante on capte pièce quand même
d'accord
pas d'accord
ok ok maintenant qu'il verse à rodez 1
us peace c'est ce qu'a informé des
changements ça déjà moi ça je peux pas
croire
que la miss
météo il joue très vite tous les deux
c'est sûr que
c'est limite s'il sont pas en rien texto
à la veille pour dire on continue pas
la maison tu vois si vraiment il quelque
chose là ça se voit que lui ça faisait
je venais d'avoir tenu le grand écran
yama des f 5 km 3 4 4 ni l'envié n'y
était pas c'était pas une prédiction
c'est très difficile
il fêtera
les 40 selon fazil say que benoît re la
nulle sur commande pour tout le monde
bravo belle partie
oui l'année noire
que tu veux mais je souffre je trouve
pas ça coule plus à quoi s'en tenir
comme ça c'est pour le coup tu peux rien
mais bon c'est juste le ne veut pas
jouer avec les blancs je ne sais pas non
plus
car c'est ni l'aï respectée m pas matin
à keane
et
voilà non mais c'est quoi avec le même
document mais la vrai tu vois je pense à
un rapport à duda
à champlan il
[Musique]
va laisser ça de côté
efficace à l'échauffement ça donc du
coup alors partie intéressante que ce
qu'on a
alors que tu vois je bon tu sais
toujours pas qui je veux aller voir ok
je ne cherche pas
mais en fait mais en fait intéressant
parce que parce que c'est la même
ouverture qu'il avait joué contre eux
rapport des comptes avec kevin et on
avait un petit peu la théorie en direct
parce que j'avais travaillé avec
quelques années j'avais un fichier
dessus ok
combien de points
je suis là je pense un point et demi
c'est bon ils à s'en prendre plus à dire
calculés pour la revanche de 2009 je
regarde il fait nul contre eux duda qui
à 27,60 donc l hyper un 2004
il a 43 comme ça donc 25
mai et contre chant clan il perd deux
points
ça s'arrête dès qu'ils allaient noir
tu fais moins de 1700 à l'eau tu perds
tu perdre deux points et tuba 1,2700 qui
gagne 3 points donc en fait pour monter
le vélo c'est sacré en
2007 et c'est quand même pas évident et
puis puis bon il suffit que les mains
qu'il ai pas envie de jouer pour le
battre
même avec les blancs tuba pas de temps
quand tous les jours en face s'est pas
tu fais pas de surmoi quoi 2007 même si
la lac léman il
a raté un
salut mariage château
salut à toi lui aussi salué mme dhalla
là nul c'est en sa carrière
propose des clips loi et que le multi en
baux
ont du coup et un quart d'heure voilà
alors du coup montre nous que ça donc là
il ya eu ouais donc avec ces trois fous
de 4 donc la magazine elle dame ces deux
tireurs à trois fous pourtant il des 5
et fouillent les cinq c5 c6 théorique et
pu reprendre sans que ceux-là même parti
que contre duda donc
rapport où il y avait eu des princes de
5 des 4es rapport avait joué ici
non parce que sa partie
rapport il avait le damage et 3 août la
rue d'alger trois cavaliers 17 il avait
joué cinq barrières
voilà ça et là du coup la vie d'ahmed
trois équipes où moi je crois est un
coup j'ai donc lu sujet pas leur ouvrir
un mais
mais je crois qu'ici le coup il y avait
des dames je crois
ouais
ok donc il veut manger ce sac est vieux
jeu pour eux cinq aussi et donc 3 rapide
donc du coup vie dit il s'y prépare et
là dessus il a vu la partie de deux
rapports qu'il a travaillé il a fait ses
devoirs et en plus il à 1h41 donc a
priori et c'est ce qu'il fait avec damas
3 et 2 3
oui la population n'a pas perdu à cause
du répertoire il avait une très bonne
position donc si la profession ces
lignes et cetera n'ya pas il n'y a pas
vraiment de quoi
changer un
risque à malley
ok donc ça reprend la partie d'hier de
duda
donc que 5
goudjil option
cave a lieu deux pressions bekkouche
et elle a d'étranges
donc bon prague il est comme un loup
cammas évite donc
le secam ce qui fait aussi andrée fou g4
entre la dass pascual
g 4 c'est la partie c'est la partie
de
hockey si je mange la dame je mange la
mienne et je peux manger là tournage d
une qualité mais tu es comme des pions
en qualité et tu vas jouer après
peut-être des quatre cavaliers matin car
étrangement des cinq et il ya une belle
compensation pour la qualité de son coup
de pied contre tours il ya d'autres
surtout plaît mais cette structure même
si elle a dû redoubler plusieurs ne
m'avait pas si mauvaise lorsqu'on a des
gros blocs de pions d'avoir un 4 2 qui
va être bien compact donc il va être
dangereux comme tu vas dire la classe
des ce1 qui peut être intéressante
j'aimerais m'installer une pièce qu'on
en a deux susceptibles de lui tel pour
la case et même ception double r il
contrôle le centre ça
c'était une position intéressante je
préparais ça chez lui et voir c'était
facile potage ou en pratique pour les
blancs et
il n'est pas rentré l'instant j'ai
l'impression
ouais non mais je pense qu'il est dans
la théorie il à 1h30 à la pendule bons
doigts c'est grave tu perds et c5 donc
dame à 1,5
c koi d'alger 3 points
l'apprend ce
5ème mais des mistakes à la folle
ouais pas d'un style commencé des cours
normaux
et
pour t2 pour libérer le fou qui va
défendre ce pion moi c'est vrai que
visuellement j'aime bien les noirs
voient l'appareil a purgé gatineau il
serait peut-être mieux ses doigts et les
gambas et m cette colonne cei à un
verdict qui affaiblit
avec leurs perspectives mais
l'ajustement sans calculer sans rien son
gardien messin quel intérêt il avait 5
c'est en estrie et justin joue le roi
valet
premièrement tête est tombée 8 etc mais
j'ai aussi camaïeu quatre ans je pensais
à calculer un dimpre en fous je prenais
deux heures autour des huit mois c'est
peut-être ça marche pas peut-être on
arrive à se défendre correctement mais
juste pour montrer à quel point il ya
des idées qui peuvent arriver vite
500 cavaliers ces trois mêmes peut-être
je trompé trois menaces et peut-être un
jour un cavalier avec 1.3 je sais pas
mais là ce lot de tout rendre évident
bon on voit que rapidement par année les
pièces et essayer de créer des choses
aussi il faut le style qui peut être
intéressant si ces médicaments il ya
plein d'idées dynamique et avec leur
encontre m leroy camilla s'est ouvert il
donc bien sûr c'est une préparation vide
et il a travaillé avec l'ordinateur il a
voilà c'est c'est pas une position qui
est vraiment de nouvelle pour lui oui
mais en pratique salariale très dur pour
le blanc bah dis donc si tu avais des
plans savez cette blessure et que les
blancs mais une arme a répondu les
petits connais pas tu dis que ça a mal
tourné là le
voit aussi qu'il ya des perspectives
pour les mauves et si on arrive à mettre
fin aux essais deux par exemple il va
aussi et défensif intéressant
mais c'est que cette étape où elle vise
le roi mais j'ai passé les six bien
passé que ça
n'empêchera pas trop le kazoo avec toi
moi franchement j'aime bien des bleus
enfin j'aime bien les noirs ainsi un
jour avec moi
comme quoi
il a décidé de prendre cette mesure avec
les blancs avec son ordinateur avec ses
seconds en lui il a jugé qu'elles
étaient forcément prometteuse pour les
bleus
bien sûr après inclusion l'événement non
mais ce qui est cool c'est que ça laisse
des chances pratique à prague c'est une
position sèche
et du coup on va avoir un peu
aidé par ici où il aurait pu avoir sa
chance où il a lui-même dont certains
mais où il applique des mauvaises
décisions justement un peu dans des
moments clés en milieu de joueurs ont
sorti deux ouvertures au jour de manière
parfois assez naturel et découvre un
parent ou un ciel qui qui vont coûter
très cher donc à voir si aujourd'hui il
arrive à jouer peut-être plus simple en
fait
là c'est vrai qu'il est face à un panel
de joueurs et au niveau qui n'a pas
forcément encore l'habitude de côtoyer
qui est encore très jeune et du coup
peut-être qu'il veut un peu forcer ses
coups tu vois ce que je veux dire et en
faire trop au lieu de jouer plus simple
comme ici avec ce qui ce qui lui coûte
un petit peu lors des dernières parties
qu'il a perdu moi ça me sens sinon
écoute en tout cas ça va être une partie
comme souvent les partis qui s'annonce
animé
chez qui
alors caruana richard rapport c'est
intéressant à position allait un peu
bizarre
alors voyons fait ce
qui a choisi une anglaise pavillon
d'impression transport jouent toutes les
ouvertures et là nous il nous a fait du
p3 une madame zhang est au dessus des 4
je sais pas si la jument de 4
surpris que si je me souviens pas là
maintenant il part pour l'anglais et
avez une conseil avec les noirs on
dirait qu avant les candidats y avait
toutes les ouvertures possibles pour
brouiller les pistes au maximum ouais
ok 4 c 5 alors ici à la place de ces
cinq hommes qui vachement d'achoppement
la mode et des 5e 5 des cas
et d'ailleurs il me semble que cette
pollution il me semble que c'est la
partie en ce moment de guiry duda si je
perds
c'est la partie degrés j'avais voulu
mais donc ça c'est la rentrée vachement
la mode mais c'est simple je ne
connais pas mais la botte des risques de
sa part
mais ça paraît bizarre quand même 2 5 ça
permet quand même cinq positions et
c'est une sorte de cécilia loin
finalement rencontre position avec 5
pieds qui est permis donc bizarre
cavaliers 8
et bly les cases noires avec 6 et un
problème développement alors qu'est ce
qui s'est passé il ya eu des 4
il temporise
noire
des six lots
g6
les cavaliers
pour le
hockey balle souvent comme le
développement parce que tu vois il peut
pas faire cavaliers seuls à cause de
crise n'a
pas tout faux 6
je peux pas jouer non plus fous les
trois à cause de prison le 5 il y avait
un problème sur
pour le coup des trois
[Musique]
familles du cou qui est contraint de
réfléchir il a déjà dépensé en 20
minutes avec notamment donc certainement
les sorties de ces fichiers avec une
nouvelle fois des coûts atypique choisi
par richard alors
c'est intéressant si nous fait encore
des parties agissant avec des nouvelles
idées
monde s'éclaire ses rangs pour ça que
c'est cool tu vois ce tournant
franchement bien intéressant parce que
vraiment les joueurs qui sont invités
bas et ses rangs des joueurs qui sont
hyper créatif est tellement cardiaque à
son champion du monde mais rapport et
créatif tout d'haïti penkova ne
progresse que bof
enfin c'est juste monstrueux
si on dirait peut-être d'en prendre et
qui sait que vous réussissez pas sais
pas quel point donc gp racer
mais le foot c'est bien donc du coup la
foule pourra certainement l'activé d'une
façon ou d'une autre
ces quatre maintenant se poser la
question est ce qu'il est si bien haut
ses câbles donc il est tout seul
généralement
on
va sur la table
basse je pensais à l'âme étrange destin
que ça paraît bizarre mais
je pense que le 4 à leucate ça va être
le goût je pense comme 1,4 mais en fait
un objet 5 l'idée c'est que son comprend
que je fait cavaler prend et après the
mask a lieu quatre avec roger 5 la case
f si ça peut être intéressant je sens
des affaires mais j'ai peur de cavale et
des cartes par exemple kamel et b4
malicia
nantes dans le cadre plutôt d'avocats
rcam élèves sont du coup
et
être fou détroit vous les trois
cavaliers b4 sa dallara fou
tu joues pas si j'ai préféré les f-5 tu
vas jouer un petit rôle je
regarde la 3e
avec 9 5 me font ainsi si on prend il
faut voir à quel point
3 6 et gran pas donc ça m'a vraiment moi
je connais pas la police mais s'il ya
bien
un coup bizarre comme cavalier vie de
simone en jeu depuis le ici
je reviens en juin je reviens au moins
deux fois
je te fois en dix courses personne
géniale et santé soit débile
bon c'est pas si débile maintenant j'ai
la case ercis
cinq
dans les prochaines minutes
allez voir
kirin là parce que nous en parlait
justement disant que c'est le même début
et puis je dois dire lui est vraiment à
la mode par contre ouais sur cette
anglaise on dirige avons pas de temps en
temps la langue laisse pas une grosse
surprise de loi c-4
et donc sa fameuse des 5 donc c'est
logique on regarde tout de suite
à cette rupture son ca
de 5
des cas parce que nous ne nous disaient
voilà prise prise et dans mon angle et
cavani disparaissent
b6
et donc ses 5
non moi je ne connais pas en fait je
connais parce que j'ai vu je les mets
plein de fois jonathan dramé jeu simple
que j'ai jamais joué mais alors on va
dire bah j'ai des connaissances en
réseau arthur un petit peu
là
je connais plus par un
souvenir tu vois
[Musique]
c'est
logique
de revenir
en fait le bon choix en fait ça marrant
parce qu'après cs5 et là on voit que les
blancs vont plutôt jeu sans casse
blanche avec food et cette foule c6 et
le footsie ce pourrait être assez
dangereux il est fou et fait débat c'est
le mauvais ou parce qu'il ya des pions
centraux qui sont de couleur plus
profonde croit c'est un prêt sans
wayne sera pas signé mais généralement
je pense qu'il ya peut-être quatre
langues chantées et jouées sur place
banques essaient pourtant être que fou 4
malin pasqua qui veut je fous aux quatre
pour échanger classement ok
effectivement dz 4 pouces et six bien vu
ce taux
est l'époux de casse bonbon qui ont
disparu la chine
ici alors qu'est ce que tout rebelle
hostile de l'ain
je pense que je vais devoir le faire
parce que je pas de quoi par damas est
pour bien défendre bessette et je pense
que dams est pas le couple a envie de
jouer
sur le petit roy conrad ou même
manière comment continuer avec les avec
les noirs tu décides j'imagine
la tour en prison bien que je peux pas
dire ça je peux bouger madame mais je
sais pas c'est difficile
[Musique]
pour les noirs non
du match
les blancs du bourget du tout d'attac
plus pour les noirs
la justice belge avait six pôles pour
limiter le cavalier e 5 pour prendre le
centre est installé une tour en d3 a
essayé de même ouais même peut-être même
f6 g5 avec l'idée de faire rager quatre
cavaliers bouger cavaliers le cinq
cavaliers detroit installer un bouquin
valant détroit pour empêcher de bouger y
a plein d'idées dynamique ici
ce
qui fait que l'on est là à tomber adapte
pas forcément l'idéal
réfléchit à une position intéressante
jusque là pas de déséquilibre avec
l'ouverture de douze personnes c'est par
là de la partie joueurs où j'ai
l'impression que j'aime bien les doigts
revient effectivement moi je capote on
devient
mamediarov alors bon on l'a déjà vu une
fois à bon expert douanes soit reste je
joue au prince
édouard pour l'instant ça marche il
franchement un signe espagnol pascal
eydoux hockey
[Musique]
les femmes g5 à renard juste pour info
et
donc doivent rendre des lieux
intéressants pour aller voir
éventuellement mais si peu commune
forest
ne passe vraiment pas grand chose je
pense que ça va pas durer longtemps
de ski et dernier
duel
la langue moscou
cavaler plan si la pudeur pour être
légèrement inférieure d'un cran et le
bon coup parce que le canal yvan c6
americas et
mai mais bon cavale et prendra cet impôt
qui vous sautent allemand
en france un petit peu la vente un peu
de 6000 aussi des blancs j'ai
l'impression généralement je t'aime plus
tôt c4 avec blanc en tout schéma avec
roxy ses 15 des cas
surtout que le gaz allait mal placée en
fait en dix-sept donc pas vraiment
contrôler le centre
a pris à plein deuil à plaindre il ya
plein de trucs à la branche liens
humains
qui existe
et
ce qu'ils mangent tata un problème sur
le temps mais il ya des bilatérales avec
havas et c3 par exemple 26 il hérite
damas quatre qui se joue avec l'idée
d'un disque à la libé
5-1 d'hésiter vraiment intéressante mais
mais bon ok
mais ces trois
autres me semble que c'est la vente un
peu timide parce que donc avec six dames
c'est logique
et normal oui mais généralement t'as pas
grand chose en fait dès que tu as
attentats des 5 qui arrive tout le temps
les caraïbes 4 est normal
a ajouté quatre prises prises ont ajouté
5 et sur 100 conjoncture est le
quatrième bébé qu'attend pour avoir un
peuple et son idée mais d'ailleurs c'est
un peu bizarre ce qui s'est passé crew
parce qu'après tout en cavale et panjas
plus cavale de quatre ans qui avait
acquis le pion mais n'est moins sûr
ajouté 24 et là on joue cavalier et des
deux est pas ce qu'elle va lancer trois
je pourrai manger comprend et le pion
serait arriérés à tour ces outils
seraient assez faible
ça serait même bien pour les noirs s'est
vite donc aucun rayon demande des deux
peut pas casser la structure et après
les changes des pièces est bien ici les
noirs sont gardés d'un v6 ou b4 et la
pollution al adha près égale ans c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que je n'en mange pas
trop ces trois des quatre danses et pose
parce qu'il est noir arrive à égaliser
pas vraiment un jeu est assez facile
dans top spin 4 prendre l'aventage mais
mes poubelles car ça m'a l'air étrange
parce que après tout des deux et là je
vous laisse le fou et maintenant j'ai
plus qu'à mayotte l'instant c'est quoi
ce thème du jour
ces deux là où il y avait une vie après
l'avoir déjà deux parties bien sûr mais
bon
c'est sûrement un bateau qui manage la
reprise
ok même cavalier 4 c est allé d une fois
comme ça ça défile pions après mètre
carré en dessin qui a un problème de
carte blanche et des fois il peut y
avoir des idées n'est pas
une option mais met à chanter hier a
donné un grand concert gratuit on a vu
que ça n'allait pas bien réussi geri
donc du coup vous pas suivre son exemple
aux banques la cavée g8 auquel
ont
disparu déchets et donc ça va être une
bataille cheveau petits chevaux de bois
qui sautent lemieux qui saute le plus
haut entre les deux joueurs
voient ça tant qu'un plan d'attaqué
peut-être
à la loi à partir de pages web bon en
fait j'attends
moi mais généralement c'est pas parce
qu'on cherche à faire passer ce que
c'est un beauf c'est vrai ok
mais je sais qu'en général c'est ça
donne du jeu j'ai bien normand baird on
va se cacher
e on peut supposer que les noirs ont
fait un petit rang commandera une
bataille de recomposer
ok alors grand roque
donc là moi ce que bon je pense
cavaliers cette vallée de joux et
probablement 3 b 1 et elle a réussi à
sauver la jeune et petit rock ou sinon
un autre coup qui est intéressant c'est
oui sont trois dames mais aussi le
cavalier en fait
17 qui va leur en but
voilà mais sa bonne cadence
à moins qu'ils veulent je loupe comme a
lancé 6 mai du coup cavaillé 17 tu vas
où vous aurez de cavale et b6 là ça n'a
qu'un petit peu denses
[Musique]
mais ces thématiques dans la française
je dirais la bévue de cavale et c6 et
ressortir après
tu as d'un v6 pression sur le plan des
quatre cavaliers f5
semino
la place réduite oui mais faits de
cavale et 17 il va où
oui oui c'est pour ça que je sais pas
mais moi je rencontrais cavalcade direct
parti à libyen est vrai que possible
intéressant et donc on va conclure ce
petit tour de stade avec
[Musique]
qui vont suivre l'exemple car
si l'on joue beaucoup de coups et
voilà rallongé
alors là tu veux 4,5
lesquels
il va chez sushi
c'est ouverture sept jours de montage
qu'elle prend il essaie de voilà comme
la connaître pour la tour c'est
la 2 claude ouverte possible août on
finalement avec deux jours nous plaît
c'est que noirs ici on a l'impression
que je peux a peut-être joué samak pour
très vite
égalisé peut-être pas mondial déjà donc
mais sexy elles savent pas ça va aplatir
de la position
moi je compte les charges
moi je pense qu'il a juste un jour pas
d'autres coûts et en plus cette fois ci
l'un devant 7,5 comme ça où est la tour
jo actif donc normal je je je je vois
mal cette position vraiment sûrs et
beaucoup
de
grosses même pièce grosses pièces
basterds est ce qu'on voit maintenant tu
m'as reconduire exactement ce qu'on
allait faire
voir
ado mais s'il
n'ya pas encore un cavalier 3 1 ça y est
si sa relève waouh petit robe et trois
partis
et six ou sept
jours seulement ces cinq qui paraissait
bien grosse tension
au centre donc voyons faut réfléchir de
revoir sur cette partie
mais souvent cette position
suite parce que ça a juste à améliorer
histoire qui traîne la carte permettra
une pièce noire de
surgir deux secondes on se placer au
centre
c'est cette tranche quand même comme
coup parce que
bien sûr ils empêchent dépensé 4 parce
qu'il ya le vis-à-vis comme une très
claire flèche mais je perds le comprend
de la case des quatre du coup sûr cette
année quatre attaquants des cadres
donc à voir en ce qu'il veut faire
peut-être 5 mai le 5e j'aime pas trop
trop
ouais mais voilà en fait une fois que
des ceintures rouges madame genre en d1
et maintenant le problème c'est que bien
des cinq îles emprise quatre fois et que
ce qu il bouge bien qu'en baisse est
donc que ça que ça peut être à mon cou
le pion de regarder le pont des cinq
mais peut-être des fous c'est simple je
sais pas mais c'est pour ça en fait que
ça me paraissait bon visuellement je
crois également de jouer
mais c'est clairement une idée qui doit
avoir
parce que en fait en tout cas valu un
comme ça c'est pas anodin c'est
le cas
de la mx câble s'amuse à prendre le le
haut des cheveux de médias le crâne de
sa chrétienté des petits zoover
voir cette partie s'est passé dans le
chat que vous en pensez si vous êtes là
qu'est ce qui se passe les glo médias
mais djawad manger ce soir oui voilà ce
que là c'est pas les besoins améliorer
1h35 à la pendule la
copine je tiens
cette partie de son appareil
ah
[Rires]
oui la charge de la caméra il a bien
compris il a mis la star du tournoi
ça change de la structure
de l'espace
c'est parce que c'était la partie
d'abord
le
hockey sur
le plan des cinq étant prise après je
pourrai
contre la vidéo liste
position
quand on a un pion isolé font des actifs
si on joue pas actif avec deux pions
isolés on a recent marcher dessus donc
là on voit les deux cas mais que les
quais sport c'est quand même assez
active avec les cavaliers les fous il
faut exquis variés
donc du coup j'imagine que la chanson
vivante 1 pour permettre avec un peu
désert mais si on est passif dans la
position essayé en consigne de ne pas
ça a l'air d'aller bien venu à bout
samedi brutale qu est ce qui vous arrive
est déjà alors que nos amis grâce à
l'écart yakine tranquillement en train
de s'éroder peut-être peut-être
justement dans leur salle de repos parce
qu'ils ont fait nul en un quart d'heure
aujourd'hui comme ça que déjà une
réunion ils ont fait nul un an qu'il
faisait bien la boîte et la menthe et
botha le csaj de luxe quintella sur vos
droits
donc oui la bouilloire convoyeur les
compressions de toute façon je pense
qu'il est bien sortie de l'ouverture 76
fait ça veulent partir d'hier
est-ce qu'on retrait par un saut
justement surnommée dia ho hau wah
galsi de vieux de quinze minutes qui
était assez cocasse qu'est ce qui s'est
passé ça
moi je pense que le lay lay lay film la
cub
alors
les avait laissées sur quels étaient ses
goûts
et
ses deux
hoquets attaquerait donc logique dans ce
choix hier dans une corde ouverte pour
les blondes on va taper sur nos pièces
lourdes sur solution c'est celle avec un
ordre a évidemment jamais envie de jouer
c'est 6
donc
un petit problème pratique de la
position et puis aussi une idée qui peut
apparaître deux jours gicam a laissé
cinq
contre le casque important donc du coup
la foca de bien jouer qui m'oblige à
partir
bonjour de position sera là vraiment
dans vos partir jamais on va chercher à
reprendre et que l'option on veut
toujours reprendre avec une pièce sur
quelle qu'elle soit pour ne pas changer
la structure et du coup fermer la
colonne bloqué à ce procès c'est une
grosse faiblesse il deviendrait
largement en sécurité
quand vous installez vos pièces comme ça
sur des cases et qu'il ya une faiblesse
de la connaissez toujours pouvoir
reprendre avec une pièce pour pas pour
pas fermer sinon vous perdez votre
avantage
stratégique
sur tu partages
bah oui évidemment répondre on voit bien
que le pion c'est cette simple en
arrière et parce qu'elle soit une
colonne semi-ouverte quelqu'un est un
arrière par rapport à ses autres pions
donc ce plan il est faible donc
évidemment si je prolonge du pion la
colonne je ferme et du coupage et plus
on parle que d'eux qu'ils règlent idée
vraiment cette matière pression sur les
pentes à 7 donc la fois au cadam rives
de la belgique
casar a commencé samedi 2 et maintenant
d'amnéville pour jeu de dames bessette
donc voyez là la fameuse batterie sur
la diagonale blanche derrière tu vois ça
me au revoir un thème on avait vu la
villa de par leur part la partie de
quarantaine
bref on reste avec le fou aux 4 vient
clouer le crédit est roi et en fait
c'est ça le foot et 2,5 et simplement
parce qu'il défend le roi et en plus
qu'à une belle diagonale mais du combat
que le foot en baisse est à la fois en 4
va s'échanger contre le fou j'ai deux
pour en fait à fait bien droit d'entrée
dame bessette les cases blanches ces
loges du go que le son casque blanc
seing vous qu'on a le cas ce banquier ci
et là il ya eu cavaliers hcap km2 un
échange les
prises prises et auront huit ont
probablement leur idée de jeu eu cinq ou
rien o bella position c'est certain
parce que c'est moi ne veut pas se
permettre d'être trop passifs les blancs
présents pour triplant sur la colonne
c'est
ici sans échanger imaginons les
cavaliers disparaissent tous d'échiquier
on trouve qu'avec les pièces l'odeur une
grosse pression sur le pion c'est
peut-être on pourra tenir massivement
mais est clairement les plongeons à
leurs mains il sape est très marrant
pour les noirs qui doivent me chercher
un bon actif ces notions de manière à ce
qu'il appelle un vc-25 pour ouvrir des
lignes peut-être plus mais se crée une
tension ici
imaginons que s'il arrive à jouer au sol
par exemple et si les bleues ont pu le
rester avec leurs pions de rester au
fait qu'ils avancent mais non pour
consolider sa part des trous sur quatre
manches mais imaginez un cnir avertit le
roi donc voilà vraiment et qui veut ces
sacs
kalyev casse et ramène ce qui veut dire
au jeu il vise certainement agacé cinq
ans ouais
cavaliers de voir cavaler c5 ce serait
une bonne nouvelle
si
le candidat le plus logique ces pièces
voient la guilde games d'as
ça va connaître
une question je pense que vu cavaliers à
l'arc logique
mais ça laisse quand même ça laisse
quand même la casse ces 5 alors que si
je mange de la tour eh ben pour être
doublée sur la colonne e et savez faire
à la casse qui
voit c'est une position
encore une fois
rien
d'inquiétant pour mamediarov qui avec un
jeu dynamique devrait pouvoir
ben ça peut déjeuner parce que tu vois
que le roi blanc cammas est faible a que
trois ans g2 et après le saint christ
cavale et prend un jeu pourra d'un
cavalier en jeu 4 bon je peux te touche
la main comme les pièces pour attaquer
on que rien moins qu il se passe des
choses on va voir un
set
à négative c'est à partir des propos
[Musique]
quelle va être leur de la première
pousse tous foutus meilleur moment pour
vous la page de youtube on a tout vu
tout l'échiquier
vous rappelle donc à démontrer qu'à
celle des karzaï à qui
on accorde aux trois partis qui ont fait
pareil d'actionnaires je vois contre les
deux jours hasard c'est très chaud
donc je propose que juste après la pub
on revient direct sur visitent prague
avec un roi blanc qui ont besoin de se
faire attaquer moi je pense que là kevin
est en train de flipper pour le sommes
là on sent quand même que m pas mal de
jeux seynois bon trouver en quelques
instants et on va on va essayer de faire
un petit point de tueur
[Musique]
à
m
[Musique]
sa pomme
m
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour et bienvenue à
ceux qui nous rejoint la pause tu vois
la trabi malaisien fille continue son
petit jeu avec le caméraman jeu de
cache-cache les mis sa capuche il
l'envié ni à son copain la partie entre
les deux joueurs indiens ont mis un
petit peu d'artifices sur le homme david
sagno
lutte au salut arnaud bienvenue à vous
sur le stream
alors du coup cette partie sami et je
vais vous décrire on était resté là et
qu'elle eut ce fameux grand rabbin
savait que visite pour ceux qui
n'étaient pas au début il est en place
et certains je dessine une position qui
a effectivement l'air
prometteuse pour le temps est vraiment
dangereux voilà
la colonne cia leclanché 15/3 un peu
faible et un retard de développement ça
fait assez peur mais dans cette position
il avait une heure quarante et quelques
uns à pendule qui connaissait et vous
allez voir que des retraits illégaux est
même encore arguments de ce qu'il a joué
un coup on va dire ball 6 traque qui a
ramené son nouveau c'était un dégoût
candidats
évoqué pour mettre une pression sur le
pont bagarre donc très logique dit il
envoyé quatre souffre on dirait qu'il
est beau conte d'alice lerois al dam ils
pensent que ce qu'ils ont mangé mais non
il ya bien là bas c'est le water anglais
y aurait qu il y aurait un bel avantage
aux blancs
parce que j'ai une belle majorité
mais où
l'assèchement de dams et 8 mai à lui
ok
bah
ouais et puis il va empêcher les
attaques genre peut-être sur adams bon
sens comme si c'est parce que m tap
qu'il y aurait simplement c5 et trouver
5 il a déconné
et dames c'est cette cavale et bessat
donc bon comme ces 8 il y la taxe le
pion à ses 4 et puis il invitait ma
personne
c'est ça
un peu mieux déjà que dans la colonne
mauvais
et le coût que je pense que vous auriez
dû mettre dans le chat si
vous allez nous dire peut-être assez à
son ex touche le secteur joissains
ump
n'ont droit à aucune construction de
pions
ambitieux peut-être cassé tous à deux
volets rendre le faire voler en éclat un
pied droit ou d'envoi ça fait très vite
donc je sais pas moi j'aime pas du tout
les blancs bon
vieux connaître si on va pas mettre
entre toutes les mains ne faites pas ça
chez vous à la maison ça fait peur ouais
je pense que
même avec l'ordi sait pas toujours à
l'abri de monga fin parce que
tactiquement c'est ce choix franchement
[Musique]
bessat encore si tu manges tu sais que
j'ai pris avec quatre ans la belle dame
des groupes
les blu ils vont être pas à forcer le
jeune homme
ces objectifs ici
je viens de plus n'est pas
certain que ces designers plus ça fait
très peur bien je suis bien préparé et
sécurisé
du coup
je vais m'en sortir
mais ça ce dangereux jeu quand même du
mal à
[Musique]
un mois de confiance et aussi avoir
concédé quatre d'un procès quatre dames
des casques
obligé que parce que dame parce que le
plus inquiétant le plan b car pendant
les combats
donc tu pourras et si
je préfère dans des cadres parce que
dans le bessin copie risque-t-elle même
manger je cavale de quatre d'usure
mais mais ok dam des cas ça m'a l'air
plus
[Musique]
il faut garder la main sur la meuse
6ème tour c4
pour essayer de manger en b 4 et après
on verra colonna voiliers et donc
l'argent toiture a vu damas deux même si
tours ces huit ans et quatre univers
et
a6b cinq
et six nations
jetant mais en fait que je b5 un jour eh
ben j'ai toujours joué à quatre déjà
et glace dames b3 et moi que tu es gamme
allait prendre quatre à avoir
jamais intéressant jeu j'aime beaucoup
la position de prague elle m'a la très
prometteuse
assez réduit donc
à
voir si
c'est logique qu'ils réfléchissaient
à des mouvements ça fait pas en tout cas
devoir c'est de se rappeler
ce que là ils menacent des noirs ça
pourrait être un f1
tourcoing est fin et dans ses quatre
attaques f1 et à tacle aussi le public à
l'image qu'on aborde tu veux d'un bébé
quatre attaques là et là
et ce serait
dramatique
je suis assez d'accord
casbah stop salut à toi ah oui non moi
je peux pas jouer les pollutions un joli
destin en
scellant
leur
[Rires]
projet de marcher sur les mains
donc je n'aurais pas fait lundi
il aurait dû lui poser des
bas mais on peut quand même que la
prison noire à gamma assez prometteuse
en bas c'est une pratique abbas
n'a vraiment un caractère des concerts
et
l'attaquent aucun civil
en pratique c'est que c'est là quand
même pas mal pour mémoire est
sacrifiée
j'aime j'aime les initiatives d'ici si
les perspectives noirs ne sont le plus
désagréable mais bon clairement encore
une fois au sort pour être un résultat
souvent dans les parties de prague et on
va voir si comme souvent
ça a mal tourné pour ton petit prodige
le soul et pop moi j'aime bien aussi
j'aimerais bien qu'ils ne perdent pas
une quatrième partie de suite ou à voir
mais ça promet je pense dans les
prochains où ça aide vraiment
déterminant est ce que est ce que visite
va réussir à sécuriser changer l'état ou
pas
il allait voir
alors ben caruana rapport je te propose
d'exploiter choses marrantes
la karma il est créatif la partie même
jusqu'à 25
alors
[Musique]
attendez quand même plus adam karch
paraissait pas vraiment l'ambition
s'est passé
c'est pas ce qu'il ya de plus intuitif
le fameux kg on perd on décourage un
petit peu d'avancé en début de partie là
les dames ont disparu de plage
agissements d'intégrer les moins graves
et à 25 le but c'est pas se créer un
jour arriver ici à vie on va
certainement vouloir prendre le sont
peut-être un jour aussi peut-être parce
qu'elle 4 j'imagine stuff la moindre
dans ses ambitions
mais bon l'idée principale c'est que
saint paul chicago le taf on prend
contrôle de la case de garde et
peut-être aussi aux malades de rami
cabaye en bref cet avis ou gagner un
temps sur le fou enlevait 7 j'ai
sûrement faire le gros rock ici on
soutiendra le sens at elle
assuré
moi je n'ai pas pensé
bah moi j'aurai je garde les cinq mois
je vois ça parle aux dégâts
[Musique]
bah ouais
mais rapporte toujours aussi original
cette décision
soit ce pic
avec chaises conserve du pitch s by step
c'est un bon concept un bon pseudo
petits
et grands qualité je m'aperçois qu'ils
gardent le temps immédiatement sur le
fond
j'imagine mal
ça paraît assez logique tout cas les
médecins quand même
et là du coup tous les fronts en
belgique je me cache inédit pour ce
match assez
je pense que ça
va un parti ou de mettre le fond c'est
simple c'est une question de goût
bah ouais t'as ps2 qui est dur à
défendre qu'à monsieur fillon est un nom
tout à fait
alors contre attaqué tout de suite père
de kate bessac a pas été joué par carla
mais j'imagine que je devrais juste
et vite
h/24
[Musique]
que je pense pas que y ait de problème
avec découverte près de 4
non je mangeais donc validé francs à
tour mais quel est l'âge de glace au
citron caviar deux genres présent
cavaliers b8 répandre caribe
saint-pardon 4 2
c'est encore le 2016 pour la pause ce
sera certainement le droit sa tâche et
ont menacé
les blancs qui perdent du matin sept
ballons perdus un pion evos à récupérer
à tomber mon père du dossier donc
ça donne ça donne rien sakai et b5 juste
un coup dur pour chaque
sac kardon s'est pas aventuré avec 7,7 à
darwin l'idée de cette île à l'autre
- oui c'est
donc intéressant grâce il ya va dépendre
le 5 g tour des huit empreintes au grand
fils at
il
donc le magic avait les processus le
processus et tour des huit pour prendre
tout ce qu'on menace
j'aime bien aussi c'est qu'on libère le
thème cible
j'aime bien qu'avec le 5 aussi est-ce
que je peux je cavale et
vite on est ici
ici
car elle est française six
mois parce que j'aurais bien aimé
j'aurais mal à prendre j'ai cinq enfants
mais frontline et
ouais mais du coup je prends 6 ma
structure avait quand même bien abîmée
musée la part de flou pour toi aussi tu
arrives de en l'air
sur foi jusqu'à des g5 vienne le fou
un
geste 104,4
donc non
du rigolo
en d2
alors ce cas là ça va en fait je mange
ajouté je mange je peux qu'amélie g5
maintenant qu'elle sait que
3,7 km et si c'est pas mal fois six
ou sept ok bon sarah d'adhérents
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres possibilités
ça m'a l'air calmes moi je lâche comme
enjeu c 6 après je mange injustice et
après j'avais fait un congrès
3g
3g 3.92 se fout je veux aller au
hockey mais c'est du tour 17
faut se rendre à ses besoins
en fait je joue dynamique jeu
j'en ai marre des femmes qui chantent
sous les
attendait de ce quart du temps et à
temps de s'activer des fous
je crois que c'est grave c'est parce que
c'est avant et l'avant
après ce prix ce cavalier g4 qui serait
chiant
si à ça et vous autrefois ouais donc là
on va manger je pense alors dit et ça
se voit sur quatre
ok et à ses pensées
ne pas perdre le pion
alors est ce que qu'ils font c'est
terrible
pour cette position finale était plutôt
intéressant entre celui qui n'est pas
très bien placé
bas après ça dépend si j'ai un trou de
concret parce que les réponses
n'y a pas de besoin de rockets
alors je mets le 5-5 dans la case des
cinq ans pour faire vraiment
parler foot roi près ce prix
et après tu mets le foie en f3 ou angers
2 et il ya quand même une petite
pression blanche parce que
[Musique]
bien après mme sur le foot or contre la
carte blanche 6008 le couple intégral je
rangeais de weppes froid et on voit que
je veux cinq faiblissante pour plusieurs
choses commerce et casey sac
j'ai pas envie de l'afjel efforts sont
maintenant ici mais pour le long terme
j'ai la caserne quand même mais aussi le
pion le pion
f5 qui était un peu peur à 81 jours qui
pourrait arriver
donc
fou de tours est fin et puis 3e des 4
ses deux voisins peu d'affaiblir ses
cases se plante que le plan f5 qui peut
être fait j'aime pas eu sept mois de
chômage
près 600 espèces
et ce prises
ici
ouais mais hc sujet
3,6 donc c'était avant je pense de jouer
devant sa science
je vais pas te prépares
après encore cavalli détroit qui a un
coût
mais là je l'offre légale la main je me
fous des 4
et puis la travaillent en russie n'a
rien
alors il ya quand même qu'avec le foin
en prison angers 5
mai à cléder et d'ailleurs son cavalier
3,50 le foot en prison est prévue demain
[Musique]
en sus on les prend
là il mangera pas les agréments donc
cesser c'est obligatoire ce tour des
riches
ouah ils pensent qu'on t'en va pas nous
faire de
régulières sur le canal
ah
ok on va les prendre apprend s'était pas
l'idée aux 3 et du couffo 3 maintenant
c'est pas obligatoire vu que le foulée
par emprise moi je suis à trois fois la
wii mais un
[Musique]
ok ok ok il faut 3 cavale le 5
ok mais là je peux je vais peut-être g3
quand même à mais j'essaie 80 après
ok mais fujitsu
ouais mais quand il faisait 6 je mange
way est en fait un
bébé 3 pouces et six du coup
d'autres cavaliers n'ont
peut-être
pas ce qui s'est passé il ya des prises
en six présences à six est fou et 3 donc
regarder ensemble juste avant
non je pense que d'en manger c'est un
grand un père n'a
plus prise et
donc là on s'attendait à quoi encore
c'est tony woody
et sur 7 mois j'avais bien mettre le
fourreur soif ou o2 et le wave 3 mai sur
fond du pouvoir cavaliers le 5 qui
empêcherait wave 3 et 4 6 4 et c'est
pour ça que d'être g3 est préférable
à ce que ce qu'on peut parler d'un coup
comme nos cadres
parce que l'idée c'est que je peux
manger ou voilà qu'on a eu le malheur
pour être cette voie
mais qui est simple ouais possible
donc
non je jamais les voir ici la main
revenir en arrière je n'aime pas mon
coup
[Musique]
sur coup j'ai deux tu agis comme en
foot des sages préfère ici et là je
pensais comme
4 maintenant tu as plein 4,50 m avait
essayé d'ouvrir un peu version r 4 tout
prix ce pré
retraite autour et fera avant de se re 4
et c'est de faire un cadre des lycées de
manger enfin trois interceptions en
centres dépendant du coup
d'avoir ce qui se passe
je compte y est revenu je veux aussi
voir dufoir jeu 3 1 maintenant qui est
sûre j'ai eu 4 il ya un problème ce sont
tous des zep il ya des idées pour les
blancs
avec pas mal de particularités de
différences de structure qui crée du
coup vraiment hésité
de part et d'autre et salut à ma vie où
ça va merci merci à mathieu c'est très
sympa de sa part effectivement mathieu
qui distribue en même temps le tournoi
les analyses de mathieu y sont
évidemment
pas seulement ça c'est sûr un amour au
but des chèques géants des premiers à
regarder nationaux street
je pense qu'on a bien d'un explorer
cette position de faire rapport du coup
on va peut-être aller voir ailleurs ce
qui se passe mais j'aime beaucoup les
blanches de pollution en commun je me
traîne tu vas même la fois je crois
comme cavalier ou 4k m'a laissé cinq il
ya quand même pas mal d'idées
moi j'ai confiance clairement en caruana
il est chaud il gagne deux parcs
d'affilée mercredi si la pièce sur pièce
sur sur kawala
pense que richard
va contrer
du coup
qu'est ce qu'est ce qui te chauffe comme
parti on a
alors atteint tout cela je me pose une
question sur ce qui va se passer dans la
partie de leur
âme et c'est marrant parce labarthe
prague sa vie dit ça tient à un fil or à
l'heure du
web sur thiès comme
la partie de drague
ah oui ça me fait grandement plaisir
alors donc là il s'est passé quoi dans
la partie
était à d'un point 4 m
joueur déjà
d'un prend quelqu'un qui a vu tomber un
bon là on avait dit est tombé un grand
roque des quatre exercices
mais en fait c'est bien cela veut dire
avec d'un v6
n'allons pas trop vite en besogne
analyse pas la double imposition
on était là pour attaquer c'est naturel
et pas avoir peur du crack pour pour
jean-christophe ça perturbe aussi jean
est à
sa 3e sélection risque de diviser du
coup
ils envient 10,4 d'iris ok ok
et je voudrais mentionner ce qu'aucune
somme est riche il est pour les noirs de
forcer les changes de da soit de tuer
dans l'oeuf toute velléité sur le roi et
une finale qui me paraissait plutôt
prometteuse pour les noirs même si monde
à la regarder sur petit rocco
donc la petite nuance c'était que ici et
là je rappelle ria la cour derrière on
peut pas parti réclame ici on veut outre
ce pion arrière et c'était plutôt bien
pour la noire
le même thème
mais dont quelques
déceptions c'est ça qu'a priori il va
pas faire long feu sauf à y aller comme
ça dans ce sens la foulée
3-3 il a loué six avoue que tu avais si
on vise à agir pour prendre le contrôle
ou simplement des cases jeu du cavalier
blanc
ou
donc on avait tort par les deux f6 même
g5 un projet card pour des vieux cadres
et de la défense des pions centraux
et donc le droit de partir c'est logique
finalement c'est mieux que le petit
roman de regarder tout à l'heure puisque
dans final le roi il sera mieux au
centre plus proche de ses pions il a
rien à
cacher sa quête est joué
par duda
écrivait-elle ainsi si la tour blanche
sont là on va menacer g4
donc toi il doit gérer ça c'est papa il
a loué h3 ce qui laissera parfois des
petits trucs tu ramasses de g4 qui sait
qui sait ce que l'avenir réservé à la
position
il ya toujours cet enjeu
je le branche ou
alors il se passe quoi sur un coup comme
lecavalier à sac la haye car elle il est
blanc
c15 ça serait assez catastrophique pour
les langues ce qui aurait des moeurs ou
de partout sur carte blanche
donc
on est très important ici bientôt plus
beau mais c'est un 4 contre 5 1 4 contre
2 pardon qui est neutralisée
on va pas se faire de pour basse et même
sur le long terme
moi je préfère les noirs
fouquet paquet pas très bon et puis
structure sur la même couleur mais si on
arrive un jour à récupérer ces cinq
échanges et les vous sera très bien
et ben moi je préfère les blancs
s'annonce
peut-être ou mettre un cavalier en 1/4
et le g4 j'ai l'impression que j'ai
bon tournoi j'ai pas aimé
thor way
est tombé 5 par exemple
forcer à le guider
le patron de la colonne des structures
annonce c'est moi ouais mais le prochain
coup je vais tomber 5 et puis je veux
mettre le cabanier en tout cas
ok c'est ça dont 17
bizarre un comble si
ces jolis atours h 4 non
sans
saluer l'initiative
bien même la vallée blanche et cape
rouge et capoue souffre à l'épreuve
trois trouvé cinq autres partis ensemble
non mais au début mais je m'en fous je
gagne de
15,5
à malibu jusqu'à balayer 4 en 4 4 2 avec
de tomber un
gros
serveur
non j'ai récemment mais j'ai une
pression comme qu'avait lieu 4 pas du
cas malijai trois cavaliers
[Musique]
mais ok banque avait le cas train de
prendre fin
et aimable de puce a5 qui contrôlent des
cas
où maintenant que j'ai perdu le pion h3c
mince et marin c'est moi je suis moins
fan
c'est pour ça qu'il a mis la tombe et
indiens
pas parce qu'on fait du trouble peut y
avoir une nulle comme ça peut-être
ça j'avais déjà
tout bougeait c'est une possibilité dans
cette position
bon bah voui voui pour bd un
regard de sa tour accolade h aniche
cavalia sera donc il était de forcer
il fait quoi maintenant sur 24
un petit peu interrogé 3 2 à gerland
mais je suis quand même content moi je
repars été provoqué et j'ai créé une
faiblesse aux espoirs et aux trois dans
la réponse c'est pour ça qu'il a mis
sept tours et de l'autre
vous regardez une protection là je
repars ce pas là c'est parce qu'à
chaque pour doubler
[Musique]
partout
on va voir moi je suis encore une pièce
sur la loi rsa
a besoin de connaître un kevin
donc cette pression ça fait très mal
ouais mais bon maintenant que j'ai vu
tout acheter à bas je
mets mes 144 avec un pion de plus
[Musique]
parce que si j'avais tout a changé dans
la place et m autour h 4 nages est tombé
5 km de gaza
c'était pâques c'est déjà ça se passe
non mais il ya 3 4 c
mais sans courage 4 franchement je
parlais m'en vais réfléchir qu'est-ce
qui pourrait jouer d'autres
le patro de coûts c'est vraiment dans
l'esprit
de la partie 3
3 2
si je fais tout cas c'est ce que la
géorgie si
je pense qu'un ménage pas pareil que toi
sur en fait si tu récupères un plan sur
la colonne s'ébattent admire structure
quoi
qu'ils fassent
attention parce que siguiri venait à
perdre avec les blancs tranquilles à
nouveau le plomb de maquens hadja
il demain et vous une p'tite blan
carol-ann ware toubab blanc ouais donc
de voir avec la loi qu'on devine ici
peut quand même 15 remarquez le point et
pourrait
rester en ruines
a déjà signé déjà 6e
[Musique]
si di rippel et il aurait au moins
lorsqu'on a encore quand même des
joueurs à 100 qu'il n'y en a 8 et me
dire enfin sa canne ou 109 il pour
arriver à six et demi en cas de victoire
et avec un seul
être un geek me voir
mais le mythe du loup prague avec des
blancs
pourquoi personne n'a fait nulle
parce qu'il avait les droits que kaya
qui n'avait pas envie de jouer et il
aura peut-être qu'un seul drida de la
vence s'est pas fait prendre des risques
avec les noirs contre un joueur aussi
solide qu'elle cariatides à ce niveau là
son adversaire il veut vraiment pas joué
as tu peux tu peux pas dire ou pas à
faire le français au patin pour tous
encore une fois dans une situation où
toi balla nul c'est un bon résultat
comptable grâce à terme de lots il perd
un point et demi mais bon si tu vas pas
griller toutes les parties donc
consolider son avance en tête et
commandes il essaiera
de remarquer le bois et les pièces
blanches de noter après deux matches que
demain sera une journée de repos
m'écoute je te propose de
notre position
ça c'est clair et à qui je le dis mais à
la fin j'ai quand même si elle n'est pas
rien j'ai des multi ça je ne vais pas
changer de tenue
alors est-ce qu'on peut retourner voir
prague il plisse blaise disent
vrai c'est hyper chaud à avoir c'est
hyper chaud et il n'y avait pas quoi
pourquoi ordinateur donne un vin blanc
c'est un peu
basse et qu'il a
donc du coup là il y a eu il ya eu des
cinq comme la rosée
et
à 5.5
il a bien pam aux gens s'écartent comme
pour ses petits monstres
bien jouer b5 tout de suite pour faire
mais je dis d'envoi visite vous le
rappelle mon succès nous nous rejoindre
aussi il y avait joué à l'ouverture très
raide on qu'il était dans sa course près
pas bien non plus avec les blancs mais
il a droit est clairement pas dans les
poumons d'un regard déception il ya des
trous deux espaces de partout autour de
faire un tetris a gardez donc la très
attention vaut mieux connaître et depuis
quelques bruissements beaucoup réfléchir
on peut supposer qu'il est parti de ces
fichiers maintenant il est livré à lui
même mais attention il a essayé de faire
le
way
et du coup on vous prend enfin prise
d'armes 6 4 à 14 ans on avait évoqué
sein d'un procès quatre avec l'attak du
plan b 4-1 et là le point par tomber 5
et tour c'est à 4 et maintenant d'un
bébé 3 est imparable et d'un bep 3 ça
peut
ce qui me semble être un coup cavale et
b1 on réfléchit
b 3e tour et 8 c chronique
mais en fait les dames et trois échecs
après j'essaie d'aller manger bessat
complète genre en vente au 8 rue chassé
car elle est bien c'est calme étrange
parce que du coup ça me laisse comme des
casecs aux canadiens un jour en quatre
ans fait pour ça c'est d'être en
cavalier pour la vie 17,1 me set pour
aller
pour aller
défendre à trois et après d'un b 3 1
bajeux plus les chèques et les âmes des
quatre à vienne sur
un coucou
fait plaisir
merrick avaler mais oui
j'espère des stacks un mauvais coup
est ce que je le conduira l'organe
normandie pour proposer des recettes
avec +1 et demi
les mbk ça me met quatre là je me suis
dit je vais d'abord va mettre en avant
est humain
ok on b3
la mégane lanceront-ils et plus mais je
mange pas moins investi pour voir cette
finale à côté d'une puce dite admission
des actions passées mais il en fait le
piment par cycle
c'est pas tant que ses pions bessou fort
c'est que le pion à qui est passé il va
être faite facilement
le mans j'ai un problème
est beaucoup plus aussi de ce côté là
pour cette finale même si vous pouvez
voir à penser que vous avez un truc sur
ça
effectivement il a eu peur
ce qui est du nom d'un méga du coup
c'est la menace mais c'est pareil jour
apparaît
surtout à 5 adobe et 4
belges parce qu'il a raté synode qui l'a
évalué différemment que cette finale il
est bon de
wti perd donc pas être mauvais puisque
je vais proposer un de l'accord et a
dit qu on dit madame des trois qui va
sauver mais c
est surtout
qu'ils nous proposent pas belle sac pour
rester au contact du pion avec qui tu es
derrière je vais le tour b2c vrai que le
cadre est bannie protège pierre leroy
géorgie dame b de intéressant
ah oui
mais je n'ai pas
et les noirs montré que maintenant le
cavalier partie commence à trouver des
cases pour activer justement
leur propre cavaliers donc
pas si clair salut francs sur la
bienvenue à toi
salut françois est là où plein duel 100%
indien avec une position assez chaude et
le petit prague qui a sacrifié aventure
voici d'attaquer le roi dans les
courants d'air le droit de visite mais
savoir-faire de tenir pour les plans et
le canton surtout plus qui pourrait
payer par la suite
mais trois forces je pense pas qu'ils
partagent quatre mois il va faire échec
libre à toi cette fois la gema sous
contrôle chinois
wahaha
est maintenant
atteint
trop bête deux surtout à
5,9 me régale à l'action gagné 1,4
kg 4
que les mal classés peut dire genre tu
fais dam des deux
il rêve crois mon cas mais de mettre en
forme du moment mais c'était juste par
amusement mais du coup
je sais pas si vous avez des idées de
l'affichage
si vous avez des idées si pour les noirs
comment recommande la taxe sera et leurs
protégés comme maman moi notre dame qui
active mais c'est pas trop quoi faire de
ses pièces la
cage de tomber trois coups ravis de
découvrir bizkit où on peut mettre une
tour on s'est vite ça qu'on a pas pareil
c'est peut-être voie logique je sais pas
laquelle d'ailleurs donc celui que
j'aime bien pour air plutôt pour toi je
gardais avec toi c'est inconcevable
c'est peut-être fait le plus 5 tours est
si vite
je suis
menacé de s'infiltrer
candidats du jeu
parce que quand même tomber deux têtes
d'âme des uns avec un balai des cinq
pour ces deux points pour 5 mois
les châtie
bien sûr à mesquer mais les dessins
camalès et 3 réussit enfin
là la seule paix s'activent des blancs
cela dame peut rien faire avec une seule
baisse plombé sa part au câble sat est
envoyée mais
bon c'est pas gagné donc
ok peut se sont intéressés par du sto
visite qui est parti donc quand il va
revenir et valoir que c'est le seul
légal
si on va attendre un petit poulain
français comment ils s'en sont allés
marc andrieu à ce qu il restait
donc je pense pas c'est assez vite
en attendant que l'action prennent
ici
stocker ces tensions au centre est le
joueur avec les bleus ouah van damme a
décidé de jouer et se place jade un
extravagant il maintient la tension
est pareil marc andré ac sur lui très
logique de placement
le contrôle de la grande halle il met la
pression sur des 4
juste accablants -il est pas rentrer
tout de suite dans ce
bourg isolé disait qu était une
possibilité
nous
sommes actifs prenois
la ramenait son cavalier du coup cette
banale finalement pas si
on chante un bas il a empêché des
protecteurs de la fixer le taux à 2,5
donc c'était son ami v10 il reviendra
peut-être d'avoir le purise aulas après
chaque coup quasiment
voix continuent de place de leur pièce
tourne à vide de trois et solidifie et
marc andrieux a certes ici
un coup qui fait sens on ya vu commence
à prendre un peu d espace à la table
peut-être des idées à 4 jours si l'écart
est amené à s'échanger donc j'aime l'art
trois hommes dont l'esprit
et on en a à tours 1-1
et samarkand jouer il ya une position
alors face à dale est un peu petit bug
de caméras et grands des lieux
sont bien la perpet suspense alors j'ai
pas de
patronne odeur de pertes est dans l'air
pour l'instant c'est possible de la
partie
bon qu'est ce que tu racontes sûr que
cette position d'affilée au caire pour
les gorges
huawei clairement alors à noter aussi
que des fois ils peuvent en décider avec
ses quatre ans pour les noirs c'est du
passé
et d'essayer d'envoyer ici
et mettre un camion des saints
peut-être kamel et des six avec p 5
on arrive à bien
les plans ici j'aurais sûrement à 4,6
est
peut-être un problème
et c'est pour ça qu'il a 5 ça va pas
trop avec cette idée là effectivement tu
veux pas jouer à 5 pour le ccac parce
que pascal
voilà mais ça peut avoir du sens dans ce
cadre aurore decout aussi les cavaliers
a bien bougé je sais pas peut-être
y réfléchisse si tu fasses attention
autant depuis le début sa gestion de la
pompe ne l'a pas toujours été optimale à
marquant alors on allègue que quatorze
coups étaient noirs il a déjà plus que
42 minutes donc il a dépensé déjà plus
d'une heure quand même
à dire ou comment mais quasiment une
heure
de paris
j'ai passé en design yann son changement
chez les spéciales
il n'y a pas de parisiens sur ce stream
je crois pas le seul parisien c'est
arnaud paris
va lui on est sûr que les parisiens mais
les autres
[Musique]
à retourner au matador tout puisque
comme on l'a dit beaucoup d'évolutions
cette position qu entre temps de jeu des
joueurs beaucoup de temps va attendre
qu'il se passe des choses plus concrètes
au passage on voit qu'à prague on
évoquait dans la ville autour de la
ville attendent ensuite
de garder cette tour plus pressant pour
la communauté
c'est une position qui m'a l'air assez
prometteuse pour les pour les noirs
franchement 3 il aurait
alors dix pensent le contraire mes ordis
est une boîte à un calcul et en pratique
c'est difficile je
proposais
moment est proposé je retiens grosse
attaque
qui est bizarre que
bon on en était resté à du boeuf qui
venait de faire le gros
bataille je crois en les fous avait
disparu de l'échiquier dans cette partie
il y avait des médecins qui monteront b1
et sa femme aussi cette partie on a deux
qui est plusieurs fois le cavalier était
venu rentrer au bercail pourquoi sortir
et vous voulez faire la même chose de
l'autre côté manquez pas de jaloux
c'est parce qu'ils s'aimaient celle où
août ont tout perdu comme amant qui est
grande et les celanese qui a rallié la
ccsa et s'est pas amusé à faire ça ouais
et comment s'y perd a commencé au royal
alors en
début de ce2 position
mais j'aime bien moi je tu as grandi
caméra particulièrement calmes petit
rock ou même des fois des caches 4-3-3
qu'on peut attaquer et le roi et nos
clients f1 j'ai un
méga rock soul rock ces beaux jours
c'est pourquoi se cacher directeur
ouais mais quand même c'est c'est le la
ou les coulées noir je n'ai vraiment pas
la leur espace
ça va ça va compliquer et on voit que
grande et nous ça que 25 minutes dormir
dormir suédois
ont dit qu'ils parlent confiance du tout
à ce tournoi qui a
le meilleur parti il a de nouveau perdu
et sur sa chaise n'a pas une position de
faire
ce trait à notre gamme qui l'a qu'il n'a
pas mis son pull aujourd'hui et je crois
que la tuerie l'adulte de la nouvelle
critique par la cua des représentants
continuent à
ne plus jeter je pense qu'après la venue
très logique de
poursuite h 5
h schiste et g4
auprès logique un même si le roi noir
n'a par ok on voit bien qu après après
g4 g5 on voit ouvrir les colonnes g h et
on va essayer de tuer le roi
berlin sera
de même sur g5 comprend même dame 32 39
cents avec l attaque ont plongé cette et
le courage
ouais
ça n'enlèverait pas les faiblesses
potentielles
roissy les colonnes
mais grandi je suis ravie king a été
mené 5-1 après tour seraient ils à
dubois j'ai pas peur avec tout ça je
raconte à t'imposer
d'apposer des pics parterre de partout
bah je vais sauter dedans ça me fait mal
ou pas
en fait comme un hub en bessin qui
voulaient se gaver les bêtises qui avait
laissé quatre probablement autour c'est
un bien jouer sur canal et b6 de coucher
kg tour c5 qui pose des problèmes
et
est du coup la petit rush bien
là j'ai un peu du mal à avoir les idées
ce qui peut continuer sur le plan avec
les cars a dit
cammalleri chitour ce cinq souches en
quoi cette dépendance à tour donc il
veut jouer comme la dispo québec a
sûrement pour essayer de changer les
dames
se recase bon
c'est sûr mais j'imagine parce que si si
longtemps on voit qu'il est largement
retard dans la course aux jo à la taille
ne peut pas se permettre là il va tout
prix essayer d'échanger de dames
oui les courage de le voir suédois
alors je sais pas c'est du courage ou
n'est
pas du match 6 où la conscience plutôt
rock
mais là tu as djanffar h 4 h 5 jet4you a
par contre c'est vrai que c'est à dire
des trois vallées
mais a donc imaginé justement je sais 5
est ce que
là je à 3 de bois préventifs tels que
vous les regardez ensuite je voulais
voir si on pouvait faire ça ici
et ça qu'on a du mal à éviter cette
infiltration sur case blanche
donc ok
et du coup à la marche mais suis je
m'engage si ce
n'est trois j'ai tranquillement si
j'ai pas des trucs à base de
cavalli la b3
ses recherches
on appelle ça la route côté cynthia
c'est ça
ouais j'ai changé
mes trois mêmes cavale et b3
jeudi au caire dimanche c'est à dire bah
je
m'entends tu prends c'est un jeu lent
car ils pensaient acheter dans le
5/7 tour g1 un congé rien je pense
en fait oui j'ai fait je fais à présent
de 7,7
ou même même cavale et penseur gestion
des
cavaliers français en compte son titre
et je te dis maintenant et je suis l'un
blessé
c'était quoi
le bon coup il s'est probablement est-ce
que d'aller attaquer à deux jours
d'un bac 4
j'ai réécrit de la partie house et g5
avec
b4y site appel à vars égal 0-0 donc je
crois si vous avez des idées mais
comment ils sont simplement ici
c'est que dante
je prends un schisme mais son centre est
noir
c'est qu'on triche tuft mahmoud
ordinateur on sait déjà qu'il y ait des
droits
ce que j'avais dit du coup qu'est ce que
vous avez stoppé
caballé b3 akébé
3ième j'avais voulu manger là pour
commun comme un débile
dans son sens en fait t'as plus personne
achetant premièrement j'ai
tapé tout ou rien surtout quand à côté
d'un petit max qui fait qu'à mon avis je
t'aime pouvoir m'en sortir
d'un point de vue face à face à peu
rentrer là dedans
pour ce qui est des hommes comme lé foot
ouais la peinture pour la
supprimer
dargaud qui réclame la pioche il va la
voir là je crois est passé on avait
passé là
bas juste conclure juste sur cette
partie civile et a manqué à trois jeux
par du bois pour empêcher quand même
tous ces dames
cette grandiose qui revenant des fonds
ses grands débuts sur moi c'était
changer le plus de pièces possibles
quand même
on réduire les attaques et libyens de ce
cavalier c'est qu'il va combler des
trous sur luiz silva stéroïdienne
peut-être que ça va tenir pour la voir
la réponse après la pub on cherche
trouve yes aptitude à tout de suite
[Musique]
à
et
[Musique]
e
oh
[Musique]
je suis de retour les amis sans stuff
nous fait une petite pause grâce procès
devront bien parmi nous
l'ordonnera minutes a eu besoin d'un
café on voit des gens et ce toutes les
maisons de
remplir le motard donc il sera de retour
dans quelques minutes et en attendant
j'ai mis la partie qu'on était pas y
voir de plus en ce moment donc c'est
peut-être pas la plus passionnante vous
va juste faire un sort à pile entre
super pippo emon forest
j'ai pas le spice t'aime et tu crois pas
mais est passée en direct comme but est
donc cette partie on avait vu ensemble
[Musique]
dans une position et cavaliers poudre
fou et deux ouvertes pour les blancs qui
crée un déséquilibre qui pouvait donner
un peu d'intérêt malgré tout on était
assez pessimiste sur les chances de
devoir beaucoup de jeu puisque
placé il ya rationnement arrive à jouer
fc riquet c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé par une telle partie lahoud avait
renoncé fc et le reste il n'a pas hésité
une seconde il joue plus vers l'avant
qu'il revoyait cynique et après les
échanges on va jouer à salles d'aude et
pour fermer la cola et
une position quand même et pas beaucoup
de filles est a priori
dit open pour sa part 4 des cas tout se
gâte alors non il n'y a pas pas de worms
et un tweeter même si j'ai quatre on a
vu plusieurs instruments c'était pauvre
pied gauche c'était un peu retardé par
mamediarov
par contre on a vu pas mal de fois du
cavalière au premier notamment par 40
cède mais en fait on se poser avant des
systèmes base de cartes etc a touché car
souvent c'est juste un homme de goût un
peu plus souple commencer par le
cavalier c'est un peu pour feinter son
adversaire mais à
dakar en un café quand même 1,6 au
premier coup il a joué 39 et cavalières
3 b 3
c'était le plus pauvre du monde
jusqu'ici donc rien rien de ou
c est de là que ce mandat
je pense que kevin temps il veut te voir
te préparer votre forest qui vous
prépare lui-même qu'un serbe a
directement on peut dire que que kevin
terrieux peut-être très par quinzaine
alors messieurs dames des quatre c'est
mettre une pression surplombe assad pour
empêcher justement la sortie du faux et
cela quoi avons-nous forestal agit
activement comme toujours en chassant
madame et en défendant latéralement le
pion de cet espace au centre c'est 50 kw
qui me semble extrêmement pertinent ici
la dernière partie sur case blanche il a
dû sortir son fou en 6
5 c'est pas facile cette position mais
c'est pas facile pour les deux fait je
trouve peut-être pastel de trouver un
rameau à
baffes un avantage des moyens de
percussions l'aria toujours les
prochaines centrales la position est pas
morte
mais normalement avec un jeu même assez
précis des deux côtés
s'attend largement verlan vers la bulle
ce genre ce genre de partie ok gamme
désire assez importante je pense
pourquoi
labarthe la partie bascule
ok h 80 tours ainsi qu'ile rêve si ceux
ci mais le parti au g5 intéressant car
même dans des positions comme ça il a
toujours un peu le
lan vidal et si le roi adverse la bande
forest
quelle que soit sa couleur quel que soit
son adversaire donc ça c'est calme
agréable
alors si chaque lutteur g4
considéré par l'ordinateur pas papa
comme le plus mauvais ou
dans la position de départ et sabu qui
donne l'avantagé au noir puisque comme
le dit très bien
je sais plus qui dans le chatt
acteurs de la fête du sport en fait un
g4 on peut pas jouer n'importe quelle
famille couilles accalmie des coûts qui
sont pas utiles
gk juste là rien à faire mouche et 4
d'un point de vue stratégique ce canton
vous des cas généralement c'est pour
créer une attaque quelque chose une
tension dans la position de départ le
plus bougé 4,6 variable menacée
objectivement c'est plutôt un
affaiblissement que qu'autres choses
voilà exactement
ouais merci tu fais g5 1 scan droit déjà
cévennes très visible est pas parce que
tu fais ce que tu fais
hkg 4e tour adversaire il va pas faire
le petit robe du couvre donc déjà là
qu'on voit que c'est plus dur à faire sa
propre lutte aux roses et chaque filiale
adamant ch à sortir de nos supers des
tempos et apte à commencer par jour un
coût qui s'affaiblissait donc je vais
être en retard de développement avec les
plans en fait
voilà cette parenthèse et udf 3 donc il
est venu tranquillement de la bande son
action
hassine brook est indispensable pour
libérer la tour de s'accorder le monde
la colonne a eu 4 était joué pareille à
celle çi car il veut un petit peu c'est
d'asseoir les casques bleus ne s'est pas
laissé le noir même prendre le centre
est bon une position commune toujours
équilibré
et la bonne foi on sent qu il va pas par
exemple peut exister avec pour la fuite
comme il aurait pu le faire
jouer des saints qui veut continuer
d'essayer de trouver là tu es dans cette
position de cette citation de l'auteur
puisqu'il a les stations demanda pardon
puisqu'il allait noir donc pour être
dire beau jeu le siège de tout échange
et faire du bien
mais c'est pas le cas
et là c'est parti pour pour la
génération dorée colonel chez les bleus
le roi que parti on achète ok
bah moi je le maintiens je maintiens
jour j'ai du mal à voir un résultat
indécis dans cette partie après
après ça joue il n'y a pas de le forcer
à ça peut jouer longtemps m
il peut parfois tourner en 10 finales
mais ça reste très solide chalet doit
avoir aussi la position sur amd 5 la
peau
ça peut partir dans tous les sens
alors donc c'est intéressant moi
j'aimerais bien faire ça mais plutôt
quand j'étais petit j'attends de
toujours quasiment qu'on avait un
cerveau ou en cas de notre côté quoi et
envoyé le même jour
mais
du coup grâce à ses limites au niveau
rouge est un peu plus du montant d au
moins ce genre de taxe inefficace
c'est une amie j'ai gagné là est chaque
fois connaît par un jeudi soir mais
c'est la deuxième qui a reçu l
abonnement l'explication
vais déjà avoir un abonnement toi même
j'imagine brigade anti l'autre gens
s'étaient abonnés
tu vas être abonnés déjà peut-être
diamant ou passionne je sais pas qui
est ce que tu peux me dire
charcutant je sais pas quel âge tu as
déjà
ça dépend dans quel que soit le niveau
si tu joues que tu regardes un peu des
vidéos des jeux à progresser
donc
la vie cinq ans je disais ça petit même
le devoir 1800 quelque chose -
tu es très faible après je sais pas à
quel avis tu as commencé direct juste de
manière très créative c'est normal aussi
sur le principal c'est que tu prends du
plaisir et c'est vrai quand on fait
d'avoir composé se départir ou samedi le
plus sûr généralement quand on arrive
une première dans la course pour maltais
mais à un moment il ya du spectacle quoi
repose toi
et toi ça veut dire quoi et toi la
brigade anti pilote
s'est pas d'abattement étoiles or tu
veux dire peut-être
est-ce que c'est
la date de la reine s'il te plaît et le
mieux c'est que tu m'écris voix sur une
chaise car tamouls se doit ces groupes
inside bien tiré tu vas me trouvais sur
une chaise comme tu me voir mais ça
m'embête je me dis quel jour tu avais
gagné et je regarderai ça demande
plus
alors quelles parties on va les voir
mais ce qui s'est passé des choses un
petit peu
un petit peu excitante à droite ou à
gauche
et on va retourner peut-être voir guérit
pas ce que je voulais avec ses plus
proches poursuivants de de quinssaines
ainsi guy gagnon vos conneries un demi
point hier conrad à égalité et s'il fait
nulle part dont il restait un demi point
mais on a dû avec stouff qu'on aimait
plutôt bien j'ai même convaincu du tout
la position de avec la noire
est ce que nos prédictions se sont
avérées exactes
donc cavalia ça vous pour attaquer le
pew forcément cavalière à venir
il a pas vraiment d'idée quoi votre
chemin dont beaucoup ce territoire hkd
pour attaquer latéralement de 1,4
et forcé les blancs
à ce cri d'un gros pions arriérés je
suis arrivé table comme ça aussi je vais
prendre et quand même esprit le but
c'est vraiment de créer cette faiblesse
ça me semble être un bon coup alors
après tout peut-être le faire ensuite il
a commencé par tour 17
je pense que son idée intéressante aussi
beaucoup l'avaient également évoqué
c'est d'aller attaquer sperme c5
surtout h4 f3
l'idée s'inquiéter car c'est de faire
de stuff
ça marche ton truc
je sais pas salir shirt tu te fais des
trous
tricheur
et peut-être du québec mais c'est
peut-être un peu tiré par les cheveux
mon idée c'est que si on mange le manges
tu veux sauver buffo je mange chanceux 3
je fais est qu elle ne doit pas venir
attaquer le cheval
elle surprend à
bages a récupéré beaucoup de choses et
je vais sûrement avec fracas de la carte
mais je vais chasser j'ai une meilleure
structure maintenant je vais sûrement
récupérer celui là et a menacé d'actions
pour le gari siècle et encore
le même ton ordinateur soit il me fait
pas peur ce mouvement je maintiens pour
inscrire ce
week-end qu'il a joué autour des 7 mais
cette idée aussi intéressant pour eux
c'est la pro b 1 donc il faut par
thierry
va pas être très à l'aise dans cette
position n'est pas moi aussi la 3e pour
apple car il a le tour bd un
aller-retour à celle a défendu gouache
et maintenant ils repas et c'est pour
quoi faire
et duda publicis et bout d'action pour
le gard avec les noirs et là jouable
sera pas encore en 20 minutes et qu'on
allait proposer à quelle logique va
envoyer les pions ils menacent de dans
ta bulle four
c'est exactement ça oui ça ressemble
jamais à stowe film twilight saga sur
son téléphone
ce qui va perdre son titre de maître
fide est-ce que ce que vous pensez
qu'ils méritent d'être destitué
est non alors voilà
qu'on parle ou
gastro jouer évidemment données mobiles
a doublé
rohm and haas tension f4 de gagner une
pièce ici parce que le fou est elle
vouée à la défense du cavalier
évidemment bien et n'est pas tombé dans
le piège il a joué tour b 2
j'aime toujours autant les noirs tout de
suite l'annoncent et la tour est venu
pénétrer la position de lens en d3
est en train de dire un township la
table de fêtes de rigoler
mais sait se défendre en trouve ça
y est je le tour ces deux touffes ce que
je suis regardé tous
pour des renforts
pas fou et si
ben
harper défend si
jamais
à ça c'est sûr on n'a pas le même temps
déjà
j'ai plus je sais ce qu'est ce tu vois
la balle tôt j'ai autant de balles
basses il était en fait c'est pas là on
rôles on n'est pas du tout même même
période de l'année c'est moi c'est les
biens chez moi c'est le genre mois
d'août en fanfare la négative
et moi ça va il fait passer choc ça
parce que entre mois il pleut hamouma
sur tous les jours
il fait
27 quand même
avec la rue nuageux et
26 en
2000 fait 16 teintes rouges et gris qui
vient d'envoyer chier car
il veut fixer il veut se donner la cades
de quatre
vingt six cavaliers il serait d'ailleurs
le 4 mai à toronto nation est proche et
qu'un foulard
et de plus
si le g6
tout à fait
mais je crois que faible hausse lui
ouais
position pour moi sont les noirs qui
sont toujours là 10 pts le leur c'est
dur de partir que ce gris est bien
regroupé en défense mais
met clairement et des sièges pour qui il
n'y a pas un parent tendre le bras droit
pour faire nul il n'a pas beaucoup de
faux espoirs
ou à voir on va en tout cas partie très
importante pour le classement général
ouais mais on va quand même pas trop
lyrique et fait partir et on va les voir
chaque je pense que ça fait longtemps
qu'on en parle et je tiens des jeux
loisirs
qui s'ils l'emportent avec les noirs
ouais le scirocco là un petit peu sûr
qu'un seul même si c'est intéressant
j'ai à dire vous sentez bienvenue dans
cette partie médecins qui avaient encore
du jeu pour les noirs
mais elle a commencé par bojan aura
trois
intéressant de choix des
faiblesses pour une autre
à tour à 3,4 hors jeu
et il a donc envoyé ensuite
évoqué les deux
familles cavaliers sanaa chez la casse
c'est ça qui font de la tour par des
raisons qui n'étaient de froid et c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé mais j'ai
essayé de doubler derrière sur deux
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que tu
vois une fois qu'on fait tout retour à 8
on tape sur deux si jamais un jour le
blanc jouant comme trois débats
s'affaiblir et vachement les cases
blanches et il pourrait y avoir des
cavaliers 5 canadiens 3 hectares pour
profiter la gazette des raisons de la
casaque francs pour amener un cavalier
d'entrainement
défendre donc finalement
c'est joli mais c'est assez artificielle
parce que l'on tape là dessus et à
chaque
baigneur qui envoie sur les cannes
blanches il a raison je vais créer des
réseaux de ma démission
bah ouais c'est ça ou en blanc est
faible
donc il peut se passer des choses on
peut y avoir des attaques de matraquage
5h 4h trois
premiers tard
il pourrait rebondir de 7 défaites
contre quinzaine de médias directement
gb ouais et il veut être aussi je me 4,7
à peine à
saucisse
juste rajouter une couche sur le pion il
garde toujours un oeil sur celui là
maintenant il rendait souvent sur f2
donc ce multifonction aussi qui mal à
quimerc'h très pertinent d'un v6 tour
ses quatre
tours c'est justement basculer sur ces 7
de mieux en mieux la compétition droit
ouais d'accord est à toutes les pièces
blanches s'agglutiner à l'aide d'armé
leroy attention
ça me scie son trip
mais surtout
gardez un oeil là on garde un oeil là
et ce qui fait que damages 3 ne gagnera
pas
est-ce que g520 tu vas pas de point
commun c'est en tout cas un coup vers
métier a fait ce qu il
était donc en tête l'idée de g5 c'est
que lanfeust euros ht et les menaces
d'un match 3 et puis kamal éjecté
h4 je
tue proches me faire autrement parce que
toi je te nique sera plus anodins
pourquoi
oui au jeu ça les jo se trouvait
même si leur dis ça vole bas
j'aime bien j'ai cinq hypothèses
sincèrement c'est bien
bernos in style
ça serait marrant que ce colis partent
sur le monde il va être sous pression
il va être sous pression
qui veulent
sincèrement qu'on n'est pas les voir car
on a quand même ok bon sa fameuse finale
on était à fond prend aux trois prises
la jeunesse est comme on l'avait dit là
je foute la paix que destour karana
moi je préférais g3 parce qu'en fait
en fait faut deux hommes menacent
maintenant trouver 3 mais jamais car
elle est le 5 souvent qui empêchait faut
être white contre les écarts et dans le
côté on a aussi parlé du problème
adultes avec chez 4 pour essayer de
faire donc faut deux ça prépare aussi
chez capcom
synthes d'option avec mon sens et à
manger sain qui sert à partir jouer à 5
ouais donc j'ai cinq à tes jours et
reprendre espoir lasarrois
vraiment posé de gros problèmes à se
faire du mal
j'aime bien ce qui a cassé
bon
qui sait jouer h4 et contiennent nuit
des lits développe pas du tout
est ici important je pense qu'un renard
envoyé chic il veut stopper l'expansion
des blancs
essayer de fixer la structure
ouais
j'aime bien fait que le 4e choix sur la
prise en passant
il dit aussi qu'on h détour ne sont pas
en profiter c'est pas ma colonne au bout
et après juin met le plus en danger car
d'arrière
construit avec abb 1,5 j'actualise ne
l'a pas pris à ceux qui l'attaquent le
pion
est encore un coup qui fait sens tu es
un peu à l'image de la partie mais sur
mac la barre est pas content tu allais
dire que la tour qui dépend latéralement
alors pourquoi d'un seul coup la
dévaluation hp en faveur des noirs
est ce que est ce que ce goût et est une
erreur de karrada
bon je répondais casse tout
je me couchais caf
prend non joué ces deux mois ci et pas
de thème mais joubert de
la jonction jacent complète chaque fois
ouais mais je comprends le sens qui
va-t-on s'offrir
à huy
éperon gecas ge avait la bonne idée mais
mais dans le mauvais sens bien vu
la pointe de caux intermédiaire l'idée
est de chasser la tour de défense du
faux
si
l'idée qu'à l'évidence bien pensé tout
de suite c'était vis-à-vis
je pense que c'est dans la
boîte
les mecs ces démonstrations moi je pense
qu'il ya pas de cas une route repassant
avec 2,40 ainsi qu'aux gardiens ouais
tactiquement
tactiquement rapport il est là quoi
normalement
il aime bien les positions un peu
fantasque un peu je moi pour moi c'était
moins
bon aux partys leur atteint mais mais
fuir
non ok mais lui à son niveau ça doit
être
ça doit être
ça va pas tracer et du
renvoi si je suis un péno et de demander
lieu ce charcutage
aimé 5 n'a pas de bonnes cases pour
nature et tu veux pas te permettre de
toucher au cours du procès que la
qualité
a perdu
aux gardes du corps
ouais
je ne sais pas
vouloir partir un aspect est intéressant
mais sur une case blanche
je veux pas de contrepoint tu
bâtis autour des 2
contre je sors
la manger lui place et surtout à 25
c'est sûr qu'on va le voir parce que il
déjà c'est sûr oui car les situer non
mais en fait tu fais pas cavaler proche
des gars que tu vois pas les cinq
ans kavanagh là il est pas content
[Musique]
qu'ils portent il porte bien son nom si
les tours ou un petit famille c'est sûr
je vais prolonger quatre bon c'est pas
foutu ya besoin de plus pour les noirs
recours se fout des principaux points
noirs
les blancs de l'activité
ya des compensations
mais répondent priori pas d'une position
insee de presser un peu une position où
il va devoir se battre pour la 2e manche
ouais je pense qu'il ya déjà eu des
retards peut-être après avoir eu son
coup c'est possible
j'ai pu rencontrer le cameroun se
rencontrent des cons la pièce
malheureusement ouais
c'était le plus capé les adversaires
[Musique]
bon on va le laisser dans la toge et du
problème
parce que même si on pouvait penser il
va et hendaye a quand même réfléchir à
certains moments je vais essayer de m'en
sortir
et bien sûr pas de second respectable
jours derniers lors d'un quart d'heure
et salou partout où
ce qui se passe des choses stuff
on voit ce qui se passe des choses
habashi gris se passe des choses
[Musique]
ouais de buffy là il a pas rien il a
jamais fait j'ai 50 ans
on s'est un peu moqué
faire mentir il a joué quatre
ans je trouvais là jusqu'à
perdre
6-1 peut-être que sur jeu 4 ils avaient
peur aux lettres sur le sens que s'il
avait peur prévalait f5
la vidéo de la cei
je voulais dois moi j'ai présenté en
fait sur le stream je vous avais caméra
et je voulais voir la tête de
la tête de deux boeufs pour voir s'il
est en tilt en tout cas on voit on voit
prendre des loups ce qui a l'air assez
content
plaisir
le zoom et kobe beaucoup
parler d'eux
je sais pas trop car je vois pas bien
bas j'ai pas encore vu comment les
pompes à vélo on peut taper là bas je
vois là
sont ils se prend la tête dans la bad
qui est pas vraiment d'un fond
je leur amène l'échiquier
donc le guerrier h4 pour
ont trouvé cette tf 5
kgs système c'est que les noix
contrainte à que c'est de leur côté les
horizons également du jeu
hu à 2
ouais c'est un peu bizarre généralement
tu bouges pas trop les pièces ni les
pions là où tu es faible donc là où tu
fais attaquer du coup
mais rendent opposé à la
barre
ont cavalé c4 sur ce que tu manges sera
probablement des prend avec cavalli des
cinq qui va arriver châteauguay un peu
la case la case c3
a déçu c'est thibaut pas ok je vais
changer des dames la partie qui a
complètement tourné en quelques coups
finalement
ramassis logique et maintenant c est
grand disent qu'ils n'ont mangé que ce
matin je garde la dame sur l'échiquier
je vais c'est là qu'on cavaliers reprise
comme à des aveux de la
part du 2 temps avec avaya 4e vallée là
le droit à trois runs wet il n'a pas
amélioré sa position depuis que depuis
qu'on veut ça roucoule depuis
il avait cette pause cette position
at il là ça va seront bien la position
actuelle regarde
c'est comme s'il avait passé son tour
cinq fois il a joué roy l'a aidé à plat
dans la position pas forcément des
cocteau quant à robin jouer carrément il
s'est trompé il en a conscience ça doit
se rend compte que qu'il a fait la merde
c'est embrouillé
et maintenant celle intacte grande
escalade combien
pour
commencer on avance foie
gras tombé sur ce qui menace est là
surtout b6 très grosse menace
est protégée où il était très mal autant
il ya des facilités ils envoient des
shows dont philippe des petites volery
balade double affaire il a joué cinq six
coups en 30 secondes à chaque fois il
souffre oui ce serait possible ne serait
pas si étonnant que ça parce que tu dois
filer un peu un petit le tag le tournoi
de
hockey
n'a pas mal bougé owen notamment là on a
là on a eu la prise en 5 1 2 warmerdam
qui a qui a fait un peu isolé à mâcon de
rien
il est parlé de position
donc là il est hyperactif 1
pour ces deux dom descellement j'aime
bien x 6 octobre tiennent tactique danse
arrière mais a
peut-être un cabas et ses 6
6 2 c'est vraiment un jeu nomade je
confirme pour isoler le concours ce pion
son objectif est vraiment de le bloquer
typiquement sterling d'une pièce en
place et on va essayer de l'attaqué ce
pion plus tard quand les circonstances
seront plus favorables voix d'abord
assez de
ouais de clarifier la position est de
créer un blocage et bien sûr en cas des
changes en reprendra comme on a parlé je
ne serai jamais avec un pion mais avec
une pièce pour maintenir la pression
dans
l'eau reflue 5 pas trop
quelle est l'idée ici
c'était pas trop quoi faire et
d'attendre son
groupe ok c'est un peu tranquille sacrée
championne des quatre il veut manger f4
tes petits bleus ses emplettes chez
canada 4
-
cergy sur noireau les pièces
exactement
comment tu parle d'ailleurs
quatre des cinq
qui a laissé trois aussi
je regarde comme g5 mais ça a l'air de
marcher non et de 5 en mer pour manger
tel autrement
je vais lancer vitner
ouais
là je vais de cavaillé qui ont arrivés
en d3 ces trois
jeunes agresseurs g5 par exemple
mais oui la position doit qui est tout à
fait
je dirais
éloigné du micro
et s'est
éloigné du niveau
ça devrait être mieux c'était pas me
dire ah
ah oui ces ingrédients
que
l'agressif kadhafi car on ne s'attaque à
défendre il a tissé un hyper ambitieux
ça confiante que la position de marc
andré ya
débat est tout à fait
puisque acceptable ferme et directe non
moi j'aime bien ta tombe sur isolé mais
tata des pièces plus accès à la
sauvegarde de l'espace
avec les noirs jouent sur sa frange et
avec les blancs vous sur 3
c'est pas c'est pas anodin ça
c'est pas anodin bo kay est assez bien
aussi le regard bonne nouvelle autant
marc andrey qui était mal autant et
maintenant il a plus de temps que de
faire ça
car ça doit pas être à l'aise avec cette
position
moi j'aime bien apple sont marc andré a
pointé
et tu vas être déçu ça me met en voix en
chantant à me dire à qui on fait nul
je suis très déçu
ouais on sait comment ils ont fait avec
la tourne autour h4 d'ametis revient par
semaine pas fait la répétition mais en
gros la répétition implicite je pense
que c'était ça
et j'espère qu'il en soit de même
madelin ya pas voulu n'a pas voulu
prendre de risque bien de perdre une
part des deux joueurs à rester sur une
défaite bon c'est sale c'est assez
contents de leur journée de repos après
à peine deux mois dit là les noirs
s'envoient en l'air un peu de poules et
de l'eau
c'était peut-être aujourd'hui assez beau
ça suffit là je vais juste répéter des
cours de karaté ça ne va pas du tout
réussi sa prise de risque c'est un petit
peu miné sa confiance
typiquement un s'ils n'avaient pas perdu
goodkin scène il y aurait sûrement joué
ici quoi il n'aurait pas été dans le
même état d'esprit
alors ça faut pas qu'on n'est pas les
rangs le petit prague
davantage
le petit prague
alors on en est et où on tarde été
adoubé trois échecs je crois rêver les
blaireaux avait eu
3 1
ouah c'est 8
saluera au passage et merci à toi écoute
et ouais c'est vrai qu'on a des belles
parties un an nettement tous les jours
autant autant que les partitions un peu
soporifique
on le dit mais quand ça joue bien il ya
des idées d'hier voici donc c'est assez
agréable à suivre ya pas mal de
spectacles
et notamment ce tout grâce à ton petit
poulain brac pondérer ce que tous les
jours et aujourd'hui ne déroge pas à la
règle donc avec ce sacrifice de pion un
pion - et cette attaque sur l'envoi de
deux visites qui dans son petit coin qui
sait de se cacher donc la dame f5 à
dacca pour six tours saint geyrac tour
des huit matchs du couloir
on voit quelle fin tacticien comme une
fois il est dans la place il attendait
que ça notre ami stuff
y en a pas du g6 pourquoi c'est de
cacher son moi et
mon sillage les dames sekkat hercules
tranquillement ouais ce qu'elles sont il
veut mettre fin aussi deux fois
déjà la jeu il faut toujours un coup à
faire parce que
dans des cas très bien joué
devenir de la tour
c'est pourquoi ils jouent vers l'arrière
bages et la tour en prison qui la défend
juge d'accord mais
et suivant c'est un bon jeu pendant st
mais il ya aussi le pion à 4 qui en
prise
de la tension
on sait donnant rien d'un prend vie mais
c'était pas ça marche ça va pas du tout
puisque ya huit ans
un petit puzzle roche bombard
ces mêmes pouvoirs la fnam messins qui a
tourné deux qui prouverait qu'elle passe
au et dames se
mangera quatre
tours se noue ce que je peux pas tu
attaques et wyeth ont tour à 8,7
le cavalier comme ça c'est le meilleur
défenseur du roi quand il écoulé au roi
ouvre hyper dans les échecs cette future
de
de l'attaqué et pour dénoncer ce cavalli
qui n'arrive pas
à rentrer en jeu mais tout les gars sont
au point
du moins roger de mauriciens
8 à
d'après la jauge qui avaient affiché
leur style bronco n'a pas bougé
oui c'est pas celle là c'est pas facile
bon tu veux venir et du mouvement aussi
des bagues du couloir c'est un peu
l'histoire de d'attac
mais du coup il ya eu d'ailleurs
d'annoncer cette donc et la différence
et
c'est plus facile
on sait cette il attaqua cheveux
châtains en tout cas dit a cru qu'il
attaque le psg 3
ont baissé ou vous d'avoir son roi à
poil et de tranquille se dire ok on va
améliorer la position est là reste que
sur le pion
à 8 cela même ouais faut sûrement celle
ci est alors importante
une position très particulière
mais si je pense
qu'on aura toujours la dame
g3 qu'elle était jouée
un peu petit bras b
positions bizarres
ex cavaliers qui arrive à colmater un
peu toutes les brèches et les noirs ont
du mal à se dépêtrer donc sur challes 3g
dire excuse fils a trouvé cayir non il a
joué 6
il n'a passé que c'est dans ce genre
d'agressions
malheureusement
chez va
finir par nous
[Musique]
puissions vraiment très bizarre
même si l'adoption de plus ils ont un
point de perpétuels éternelle avec le
roi
les normes toujours des chances du
contre je
trouve ça hyper impressionnant la partie
est de vite
rentrer là dedans sa vigilance alors
tellement dégueulasse
je trouve ça hyper impressionnant de sa
part un blair n'a pas fait ça
il avait été séparé là dessus
ouais mais quand même c'était comme un
jeu et est ce que tu es toujours
optimiste du coup pour ton ton petit
poulain ou pas bah de moins en moins là
je la présente que le cavaly tient
mais il a reculé il arrive pas à activer
les siens
pour attendre leur ajoutant pense que
tout peut se passer dans cette partie
simon kawana rapport c'est intéressant
parce que il a joué le 5 il a présenté
la paix george iv et là on n'a eu qu'à
valider des 3 donc en fait
comment les noirs ventes il dépendra
votre question est simple est-ce que tu
peux nous expliquer sa loi ne comprend
pas alors déjà douze tomes pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent en cours de route car
voilà de gaffer il ya quelques instants
c'est pas une gare comme qui comme il a
pu faire contre qui il avait donné une
tout rond d'un coup mais les aubes did
petites tactiques qu'il a joué tour des
cartes ici pour défendre son option
latéralement et rapport pas très affûté
il a une pas mis beaucoup de temps il a
vu cahier prendre des cas
et sur la prise il a intercalé le syndic
malin pour attaquer à tous et chasser la
tour
qui défend des qui dépendrait du fou et
pouvait reprendre libéré le fond on
enlève un défenseur de l'as cannes la
tour et on rajoute à d'attaquants le
fait que je trouve qu'il ya un
pied et après ça il ya eu qu'à l'e3 et
je trouve ça intéressant parce qu'on en
fait
je me demande comment est-ce qu'on va
réussir à défendre
trois
voilages et cavale et ses cinq échecs et
on va répéter la position si on recule
3f si c'est la même chose sauf que j'ai
touré fin les royalties d'un gène
découverte ces trois suspects à mon avis
tout comme ça c'est que
nous on a une grosse force avec les
noirs on a une
médecin je dire de deux pions là sont
prêts à avancer pour les soutenir cela
arrive
alors le fou qui s'accordent avec eux
pensent qu'on peut 2d le sac juste
envoyé alors je sais pas comment mais
j'ai senti
5,5 à l'aller prend 1,5 quelque chose
qui est fou fou et quatre sacs des trans
et sous attaque h1 et ton gère g3
métro h 2 c'est moche ouais je défende
plus en quoi mais ça du coup ça a l'air
[Musique]
ou
azim en gagnant le soutien tout défoncer
6 éléphants g6 d'échangeurs achats
je pense clairement ici que et en plus
ce rapport dressé son style grade la de
plus en plus
tu vas faire plaisir qui va les chercher
le point avec les pièces noires
alors tueur et parier sur pas dit si je
te rappelle
celle de ces bâtisses et françois qui
rage
françois tirage
oui alors après le taux de précision
soit faut s'en méfier c'est un
indicateur qui est sympa qui est
intéressant c'est pas non plus du tout
la vérité absolue notamment cet outil il
découle mais c'est pas la prendre avec
des pincettes parfois
moi je te conseille de rester avec nous
aujourd'hui françois
hollande et le blick ch sera en
meilleure compagnie
peut-être
à des fêtes de fabiano avec les blancs
je vais je veux un peu vite et s'avère
très fort à cette idée et je trouve ça
hyper instinctivement le pion le sac en
fait on s'en fout on a une grosse force
ici on a besoin d'activer de tours et
notre fou et c'est notre foule il arrive
dans les rames d'agrumes ça va être
terrible pour les blancs pensent
vraiment que vous êtes
5.476 dr von arx peut-être que là qu'il
faut pas manger
je sais pas
il risque à d'autres bruits de
vue c'est ça commence et c'est débile
vous aussi ce nom
et c'est qu'on peut pas faire fou si
c'est sur cahier pour essayer d'attaquer
regarde
ça allait super six je voulais voir si
mais ça va aller
mais fo f5 faut quatre salles à moitié c
est ce qu on voit directement
mais si je suis un g3 là je me
laisserais a malheureusement
bien que
wayne quand je le faut on
j'ai appris je sais pas j'ai senti mon
cas que je sais pas si précis et juste
pour regarder comme les dépenses du
psion on a vu souvent à y aller répéter
souvent on se met dans le visage donc ça
a pas donné grand chose
est sûre wave 6 et des châteaux donc ça
allait donc de toutes façons dépendent
le plus paradoxaux alors après ce qu'on
a pas parlé de pousser le peintre
alors pourquoi c'est le pion nous paraît
pas très intéressant c'est qu'on va le
mettre sur une case blanche
on va fermer cette diagonale des fous on
va vraiment limiter ses possibilités
d'action de rayonnement
j'aime pas du tout et voilà donc moi non
plus car un monstre email caruana il
essaierait pas forcément d'aller manger
le pion mais je dirais ok tu ne m'as tu
m'as créer des fortes gaz gloire
du hockey
balle aille à cannes a laissé cinq déjà
qui est caché un oui principe même vanté
en question et 5 fu f5 le tour est fait
si le fougerais j'attendais cette et
7000 tours derrière moi j'ai loupé le
taureau et de techno et brad est plus
présent aux jeux parce qu'on sache pas
si c'est le meilleur
même pas mal aussi
sa mère
a pas de cas sous rapports une joué 46
positionnelle
et à x 6
[Musique]
des fois c'est intéressant la tourelle
peut venir un schisme pour couvrir
au coes à montparnasse y ont fait ça
pour l'instant ça par curiosité je la
regardais ce que dit leur ordinateur ils
confirment aux
éditions les modes
gagnant pour les droits donc
ça s'est fini mon ordinateur est pour
rien donc et
3 6
et 6 première fois hors cadre nous
n'avons qu'à man et des quatre échecs
sur condé s'est déroulé ce système
allait donc
[Musique]
ok intéressant est ce qu'on peut aller
voir peut-être à partir de deux rangs
des blues parce que là il se passe
beaucoup de choses de beauf qui va
perdre 5 ok
pour toutes a souvent quand à une plus
grande soit un tiers de plus qu'un
sacrifice
la sécurité matérielle quoi ça c'est
catastrophique
on était là avec la menace pour bevitt
du bois furent pas partie sur ce dernier
coup il progresse pas du tout sa
position était que derrière tout ça fait
10 passes a joué à l'envers
alors que bourdy juste lui
maintenant ça et c'est l'accès à une
harmonie parfaite cette pièce s'activent
cette forme et le ciel des ventes comme
ça j'imagine des francis adam mais
quel point de iam et du coup on scelle
cette structure qui catastrophique
ça ça ça se sent que c'est perdu
la dame des cinq chefs rouges s'ils
gagnent
déjà puis six minutes voyaient va
répéter ont gagné un peu de temps là
pour mieux se rapprocher du 40e et du
réseau
et maintenance tout fin juin annonce qu
il va
pour des choses qui arrivent à faire
passer certains voyaient le cavalier
aussi qu'il va venir passer
cette structure là c'est catastrophique
il y avait sur quasiment comme ça
ça ne vous est pas plus mal tourné pour
le joueur russe
voir la gamme et rier
deepstack du père et en des lieux cela
dit c'est maintenant ou jamais lassé sa
chance
alors est-ce qu'il va commencer par tour
7 6 mais ce qu'il veut d'abord ramener
l'écart à 6 alors que
naturellement pas trop de contre attaque
envoyez le pion à 4 aussi pour faire des
trois
mais outre ces six à coup je pense que
vous mourrez tous joué à priori à ces
jeux se mettre en face du roi stouff où
la passion dans la vie
j'aime pas de défense complètement
croit ses bureaux déménager mais bon là
pour quérir embêtements adoption bondé
écoutez mali peut pas aider est bien
placé
le premier date décisive du jour
mais je crois qu'il ya déjà 17 heures
troublées par sont tellement passionnant
d'en faire attention du temps on en
oublie de lancer les pages du club
il y aura obtenu pas là pour nous le
rappeler en plus l'occasion de voir
vous abandonne quelques minutes et on
revient juste après pour
certainement le coup de grâce déjà dans
cette partie
sur les autres échiquiers a tout de
suite a tout de suite
[Musique]
non
le
[Musique]
il
m
[Musique]
il
où
[Musique]
on
comment
[Musique]
oh
nous sommes deux aux toros tout et
pendant cette petite pause c'était de
voir ce que tu écoutes et j'ai entendu
la conférence de presse de barbus karl
scène quasi muet dessous que tu peux
nous apprendre
doit en fait il demandé bah pourquoi nul
il a dit koke quand tu vois le placement
était trahi l'année
c'est un bon résultat et il pensait que
le quart yaqing
je serais probablement contents avec
house avec la nuit aussi
voilà et après ils savaient pas parce
qu'ils se disaient que peut-être que en
fait il a il a joué à bollaert avec le
bernin et en fait
ça
le bas rhin qu'il n'avait pas eu
d'ailleurs contre 4 les baumes et hachey
et
peut-être que la changer parce qu'ils
savaient pas si carey qui n'avait pas
encore décidé dans le match en coupe du
monde
dont il n'a pas voulu faire ça et
c'est cela
et après tout simplement donc voilà il a
déclaré laurent blanc qu'est-ce qu'on
était blanc et on lui a posé la question
sur la sensation du tournoi challenger
avec here & gas iq et à huit chanteurs
et et il habite pense que c'est pas une
sensation
il a dit ben non en fait c'est le mec
que passé le plus fort et il aura 2007
et il joue très bien et c est dit la
seule la seule chose qui a un peu
étonnant accueille la cam 8 points ce
qu'elle aime beaucoup mais après c'est
clairement le meilleur oeil tournoi donc
normal qu'ils soient en tête et après il
a demandé pourquoi il pense qu'il aurait
pas de 2016 il a dit qu'il avait
vraiment eu lieu de tacticien il voyait
vraiment quand est ce qu'il fallait
faire des galas taxi coupat est calculé
très très bien même en betty rapide bien
il a été
reconnu
du match du championnat du monde et
settat et du coup bas
car c'est ni l'udc c'est pas étonnant
que la remettra 2007 donc autant
s'excuser aussi même avant le tournoi
moi il m'a vachement rationnelle et carl
terme je pense aussi qu'il aura beau
2007 c'est clair un trait comtois chaque
tournant qui fait il gagne des points
tout le temps des linges couleurs
efficace
on vient de voir devenir sur la partie
vous avez laissé puisque
bon vous semble dans les cordes et
grandit tous cas pas beaucoup de temps
la jouer le calme surprenant dame b3 ici
la répéter un emploi pour gagner mon
dieu il n'a rien trouvé de mieux que de
ce qu'ils proposent échange de dames il
se dit je voyais des combats je suis
assez surpris je trouve par ce choix et
surtout rhdp 3 y avait eu avec l'irs et
cavaliers cavaliers leur propre club
la remise a été impossible
mais je ne
vois là
mais
ici dans cette position
apparemment kessé 6,6 et incroyable en
partie
n'ai pas cherché à mater laurent blanc
et de coiffer les choquer lydia ok je
vais peut-être réussi à battre pour
l'agneau le
cavalier carrière on sait qu'un salaire
de ma tête partout en v3
je suis choquée stouff de quoi il a eu
peur d'un contre je
peux être qu'il a un peu mal autant il
se dit madame b trois attaques quand
même le plus rentrer en ouidah mais bien
sûr tu emmènes fier et qui va bien se
passer mais
ba
ba longtemps et qu en plus surtout tes
pas en confiance comme lui dans le
pendant à y perdre toutes ses parties eh
bien il se dit qu'il a une fille avec un
pion de plus qui pourraient normalement
pas lui échapper donc qui va être
quasiment sûr de la gagner il va la
jouer à 70 qu est alors que dans l'autre
et ben bass s'ils se trompent dans les
calculs moi je comprends sa manière de
deux ans est
d'accord que ça leur matin
ouais mais là trois minutes à la pendule
être un milieu cylindres extrêmement
your s4 quoi jouer rêvez pas non plus
n'a pas 20 points voire
quatre je voudrais
c'est bien sûr aussi une question de
confiance en france
je pense que je pense vachement lier la
confiance
et à raison
mais bon quoi cavalier c'est évident on
venir un cas tous ces gamins regardent
qu'est ce que c'est beaucoup plus long
quand même de passer de paracas b6 et à
et si tu veux
si tu veux on sait si ce
oui si par exemple
tu vends ses six
tezuka ouais bien sûr qu'on nettoie on
assista évidemment
la tarte à la casse et gâteaux sommet
mais plus vite quoi
me à 15 1 carton bien sûr intéressante
mais je pense pas que ce soit
suffisamment intéressant pour perdre un
temps et kaïs évite qu'ils aient bel 6
kw à
la casse b3 et sûrement aussi
intéressant si le roi se cacher et ça a
du sens ton idée bien sûr c'était
délicat ce que tu vis mais juste perdre
un temps ici alors tu as une initiative
très cette fois parce que c'est pas
nécessaire
peut-être que tu laisses pas un peu plus
de temps aux blancs pour s'organiser
je sais pas comment un vrai dire mais je
sais pas si drame de leur pièce en
défense
donc
donc ici si ces doubles s'attendait à ça
ça se voyait il était genre pas loin
d'être abandonnée et du coup il dit moi
je veux jouer une finale
sans doute perdante mais ok
bavard il voit la bande à revoir
peut-être pour un moment
même même si je comprends la question la
confiance est faux alors ça me est ce
que je fais ce que je peux te
fais mes deux choses oui
alors une nouvelle qu'on s'en fout c'est
une très très bonne nouvelle
je crois que tu peux deviner alors guiry
et deux dames ont fait nul et prague et
paris 0 s'est jamais est-ce que ça bonne
nouvelle la triade pas du tout prague
est en train de défoncer visite
[Rires]
alors du coup
parce que tu veux aller soutien dont il
peut se vanter d'avoir un vrai je
comprends ton à réglementer ce bouc a
effectivement les blancs sont un pays
mobilisé et et je comprends ton idée à
effet elle fait sens inverse bon ce
qu'en fait quand on est dans une
situation où en est en direct ba est pas
gagné certainement autant être le plus
direct possible j avais tu rates un truc
et que tu l'as un temps pu sans défense
peut-être que les blancs peuvent un peu
mieux se dépêtrer pas juste regarder
même avant d'aller voir prague je me
situe dans tous ses états oullins final
qu'est ce qu'elle donne du christ prise
3 3 wab et 2 ou à toi un recul
qui demande à rames sont plus
bas dont je suis je ne comprends pas ce
choix du tout ça me suis choqué
même s'il est pour confiance qu'on a vu
ça reste un joueur opus d'attac tu peux
pas faire ça en fait
la foule a grillé un stop et les blancs
et pour avoir quand même un peu le jeu
seulement le roi peut faire un blocus
avec les avec les blondes
pas qu'il ya pas la gagne mais c'est la
guerre il est risqué car les arrête son
nook ou
non je
suis ses six pieds surtout c'est que je
ne sais pas de quoi ils avaient peur
quoi puisqu'il y
avait trois endroits toujours le faire
plus tard si vraiment on sent que ça
tourne en bouquets
ou à laisser on va laisser passer ça où
on va aller voir ton petit chouchou
mois le met à la carte mais ces visites
cassis alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
qu'est ce qui s'est passé tu l'avais
joué j'ai trois
contrôles un peu mou quand même visite
b6 ben on a l'impression qu'il était à
cours d'idées par enda mais le même
véhicule en fait
attendre kevin est facile de cadres et
en fait il voit de quelle manière ces
cinq nouvelles cases
maintenant que la tour est parti oui
c'est sûr que ça commence à devenir
avec kamel et v3 une tour quatre jeux 6
dans tour car c'est quoi leur
des
toros et je veux dire tu vas perdre ton
secret c'est ça donc ça paraît très
bizarre
il ya une idée c'est
au coach et à tours 7 et voilà a
surclassé 5
17 hockey
vous étiez
donc qu'il agisse seul il va devenir
adam va
d'un boubou joue bien sûr va pas changer
d'un mec et noir mais pas là pour ça
maintenant il attaque le cube et 5 mai
une pression là
et a oui là c'est la course au vote car
on respecte dames 3 6 là je ne vois que
j'élève nordiques il clignote en rouge
blender under plata
avec l'idée de mater mais il n'y a pas
battus en premier en fait aussi c'est
que les noirs toute façon ils vont
toujours roulé cette grande diagonale
avec leurs dames
et d'accroître en plus surtout rashka de
2005 échec axa
2 qui arrive et c'est moi qui aimais et
supporter
les attaques
sur ses cinquièmes jo
an prochain projet d'un bel
[Musique]
bat de partout
il a mangé ici l'ondam bessac ne
l'associent au retour c'est pas une
menace pour scarlett aurait vite sur le
même mode du couloir mais en fait à fnac
avait dès le 5 km et b3 juste de
passer cette fois
donc là le bon coup le noir j'espère
qu'on va le trouver et qu'un bon coup et
si stouff battue que je peux plus voir
coup mais il ya vraiment inquiet plus
fort mais c'est une garantie nos bases
nos bases ouais je te dis pas mais ce
poste c'est assez logique
ouais est ce que est ce que l'une des
flash indiquent la bonne case
récemment que du coup
on va essayer de réfléchir
c'est le
premier clic
c'était pas la défense on s'entoure h 30
à la cité table ce oui bah c'était aller
sur une sélection proposée des cases je
restais
ouais mais en fait la seule moyenne
pouvant vraiment attaquer le roi
1 c'est vraiment de venir sur la
diagonale 1 h 8 oui parce que sinon bah
le fait de me faire des chèques quoi est
un plus une voix qui fait échec sur
aegon a levé hier à roy à deux tours ces
deux on a vu qu'en gros il faut arriver
sur une case qui n'a pas contrôlé
- notamment la case fct du cac
ouais donc damev
une heure
sur la tour et sur le plan à quatre on
me regarde là ok
ok parce que sur ok mais on en fait un
thème d'un bus à pouvoir le faire
le mef quatre peut-être
août à la reprise
alors que j'en avais plus bas mais ce
qu'a très bien géré ça malgache projet
m'a laissé cinq km et b3 qui est ça fait
sens ok oui donc il y là en plus il a un
quart d'heure
pas se tromper
si c'est le plus précieux
commentaires la place
je pense qu'il va trouver oui là il ya
pc dans le sens ira
en tacticien le petit prague et
à sentir l'odeur du sang et une
l'annoncé au début de ce stream qu'il
avait plutôt des bons résultats comme
son compatriote a peut-être ce terroir
mais ouais énergie je les ai vus gagner
plusieurs fois contre contre visite en
tout cas
et je crois que pour moi qui ai les
chefs base india
tournoi de blitz il y avait eu à renier
ni les murs et ghazi elle avait battu
par un truquage j'ai déjà vu des
victoires de prague
contre-visite bombarder tout fait on va
revenir
directement jadis mais ça fait partie de
mes deux nouvelles ouais mais du coup on
n'est pas les voir comment les dire que
tout d'abord il y avait quand même une
position assez prometteuse mais j'ai
regardé comment s'est terminée si vous
voulez télécharger cadre avait dit j'ai
une prise prise il a mis la pression sur
le pion
et là je crois qu'il a tout liquidé
c'était dur de passer en prêtant même si
des blanches a fait des blancs les gueux
l'assomption recul qui est des problèmes
concrets 1 vous plonge de 5 il
2,3
changer
de carte sim
11,5 et cela se voit
si manger cinq souffre il se passer
ce passé à sale truc
imagine bien
[Musique]
à cavaler prend et comprend
qu'elle allait prendre comprend place
aux dames ouais c'est terminé wada est
évalué à 3
ce retour deux hommes
question 4 alors qu'elle annule rouge et
blanc jeu camel et d4 et après manger f5
c'était pas possible
le cas des quatre
mois mais j'ai déconné les flics je vous
aime je parlais pas de sa maman en fait
je parlais d'un retrait des dégâts à la
place d'autres problèmes sont
ok
maintenant sur le tour des deux
surprises
devraient pas créer des cats et ça
c'est à la place de franck maintenant je
te disais que c'est une idée des blancs
ça pourrait être un jour qu'avec des
cadres voilà
voilà mais s'est stabilisée mais donc là
je sais pas ce qui se passe pour
défendre tort
j'attendais d'eux justin
c'est dangereux on souhaiterait qu'ils
arrivent la
peur mais pour ça que une fois qu'on a
pris cavalière 4 je disais qu'on peut
faire un jour un cabas db4 pour essayer
de simplifier un peu la position
dams était une dupe rami
et tuer
les v noirs team option par mois pour
moi là dedans au 2 mai le roi qui
obligeait d'obtenir la défense du
cavaliere
et donc on harcèle de leroy d'échec et
et ça va faire un perpétuel ok oui une
partie intéressante moi j'ai trouvé m
duda plus convaincant que jerry yang
avait des blancs et qui était sur le
reculoir
et la nouvelle c'est que quinssaines
compte certes en 2000 points d'avancé en
tête sur surugue leary emplacement est
gardienne orale et blanc après demain la
journée de repos contre visite visite
qui sera en plus peut-être un petit peu
affectée si sa défaite saint pierre vous
me retourne tout de suite stouff
liesse
il a joué dames cécile a trouvé 2006 ok
bon c'est sûr et ta meuf créatrice
naulleau de la cavale et c5 je pense à
partir c'est la logique un jeu cabanis
et 5 très mal et b3
de rappel qui avait des attaques plus
en plus de cavaliers 5 qui pourrait dire
tomber 3 pour empêcher kamal et 4 pour
les cavaliers detroit
ouais c'est sûr qu'il va traquer ces
cinq ans ok on va voir est ce que on
regarderait pas comment c'est
intéressant si caruana a évolué parce
qu'on avait vu que rapport était
peut-être pas loin d'être gagné il était
même gagnant et ce qu'il a trouvé le 25
je suis pas sûr qu'il ait joué dans le
bordeaux de coûts va voir ça
en était à un groupe ii
et la famille
royale n'a pas vu un peu plus on est
attaqué à jouer ce coup j'avais proposé
cheese pour regarder sur la 6ème manger
mais c'était pas plus tranchant
c'est vrai que sacrifier ce pont comme
d'aïssa ensemble pour jouer
sur la puissance du fouet les pions ici
ça va être hyper x ray carmona
paraissait ici au bord de la défaite
alors pour répondre avec ce personne ça
l'a remplacé les indiens
ils ont tendance à avoir des des des
noms et prénoms à rallonge les en fait
je ne sais pas si c'est je pense la fidh
qui lui imposait ça mais en fait si vous
regardez les noms indien là où ailleurs
sur son ami c'est enfin l'aïe a marqué
ses progrès andp à quoi
ça sert
en fait preuve d'un mandat eh ben c'est
son prénom
son prénom et ramène beaucoup sont deux
familles et donc derby son ami et c'est
comme un simple sa soeur cv charlie
wi
mais sa soeur c'est pas marrant même ccv
shalit et nam en bas si c'était sa soeur
elle aurait le même famille
mais en fait du coup c'est comme à la
can en
silence
parce que c'est parce que le sais parce
que le nom il est trop long genre en
fait le nom de famille de allende c'est
un biscuit la table regarde regarde
assez flou
oui bah c'est une heure c'est une
exception quand tu joues google ça rime
enfin tu vois c'est tous comme ça
généralement par vichy une atteinte au
respect écrit c'est ça allonge a fait un
ans d'arras pour nous parce que tous les
looks on va dire
mais je pense est un peu un accord avec
peut être la fille du coin mais ça fait
longtemps que c'est comme ça et en fait
tout est un de la mrc comme ça en fait
son prénom c'est prague c'est à dire que
moi j'étais avec eux
j'ai passé dix jours avec prague pour le
coop ça s'appelle comme tout bon donc 12
1 à brest il ya quelques années est en
fait de bague nous on l'appelait prague
du var comme simone triplé et robin quoi
vous aiderez sacre
il s'appelle pas des google et google et
c'est son prénom en fait voir canon
qu'il prêche c'est leur prénom mais
c'est juste bizarre mais c'est comme ça
et on a le chesnay cas pas ceux
qui nous expliquent que gresini rossi
qui
gère mon
fils aussi finalement
eux c'est leur pratique habituelle
finalement dans leur esprit ouais c'est
pas mais en tout cas je sais que les
indiens quand tu vois chaque fois leurs
noms sur la nature sur les matchs sur
les plates fille de quoi eh ben ça leur
prénom qui mit en avant chaque fois
moi par exemple pour twitter je vais
faire des plus de pièces com/fr déjà le
mend à niveau caractère pu faire des
princes passé comme ticket et là ça se
mérite
mais il a un nom à rallonge mais après
quand tu auras exemple d'un angle
battu comprend même qu'un amendement et
puis ces machines à dire quoi
à cette fin
et sur internet
la plupart des pseudos ou ça casse
j'avais vu coco ségou qui
braquent
il aurait pu un non match s'est tenue
hier au moment peut-être de la victoire
de
la propagande ou la prague à zongo
ça c'est dire si
la prague à ganges
et il se trouve du coup
il a encore des choses il a raté le
fleuve 5.4 que de kevin love / mange au
tempo assurément assurément
mais un petit enfin moi je veux
retrouver son ordinateur est assez
rapidement assez naturellement
ah oui il me permet d'aller encore une
station à dans cette finale
il a reperdu sûr non plus qu'il avait
gagné 1 grâce à une petite gaffe tactile
de 2 caruana sont fous étaient plutôt
super aux cavaliers mais c'est sûr il va
être bien c'est peut-être eux quatre
pour empêcher justement le fou de jouer
dans la grande diagonale et ici je pense
que maintenant il va s'en sortir famille
sentiments mais
il a passé le pire de l'impatient
bien passé le pire et je pense qu'il a
des chances de devenir alors que les
quelques coups ça peut tuer comme ça
depuis pas mal hein ouais
s'activent
inception pas s'éloigner aussi
potentiellement
non mais sur le long terme ya quand même
des choses arrête tu voyages
et la manoeuvre
j'ai trois reprises à 3% des hommes
aiment juste chez trois esprits ça un
jour 1 et le fou qui va arriver à 1,4 ou
qui peut être très très fort ici pour la
case acharnement
donc le cavalier blanc qui va être un
petit peu
contrôle des cases mais il est moins
puissant que le fou et sont tous ces
déceptions qui sont plus dangereux
largement celui ci donc
donc il va devoir craindre ici vous si
je vous ai eu 4 par exemple irois f5 je
redémarre pour l'instant basque lur à
tanger mais le cavalier peut être
facilement dominé en tu vois pas trop si
vous êtes les blancs quelque chose dans
les stades tour tu perds mais il faut
garder ce fait tomber à oued activé
battue va permettre flocage
impression que j'étais resté là
salaire durant fait est-ce que yahia
mais j'étais bien obligé trois prises et
couché sous les 4 regardez aussi pas mal
je ne sais pas
[Musique]
regardez d'options mai
ben oui il ya des termes comme ça c'est
super je pourrais pas risqué à jargeau
jour je joue à trois rois
de 4 soit aussi où j'ai quatre vingt dix
et
vingt tours 2
ben je mange moins et b2 mais j'ai pas
mangé bd parce que j'ai eu à manger tu
as mangé apache quatre
communes de marché quasi
immédiat
le thème élise et existe
oui encore de rupture en faire bien je
pensais que le plus dur était passé mais
ça reste dur à défendre y a plus b 3 et
à saintes qui est parti quelle logique
il dit à toi il ya vraiment ces exemples
je crois que ça il n'a pas de couilles
t-il avec ces pièces
n'ont plus joué le coup de pions s'est
fixé sur carte blanche à tour g8
c'est vrai c'est vraiment je reste ou
parce qu'en fait ils viendront g8 s'est
en fait mais d'assurer avec la blonde à
bord un bon je sais pas mais juste la 6e
fête en g8 une déception c'est de faire
un fief cinq fois aux quatre coins fc et
après lui à toi mais quel manque à ce
qu'ils jouent c'est ma question
question j'arrive ici
ben moi j'ai l'impression que ça a fait
que l'on pires que j'étais fixé sur
quatre blanche lui devient plus
dangereux les pions bon j'ai pas
l'impression d'être un side-car wata
ouais quand même la perdre
puis j'ai l'impression qu'ils pourraient
à perdre du temps fait
et pas de coups
feront alors deux
ça peut vous pouvez trouver envoyé à une
défense active mais
jette de l'essence faut venir ici
voilà peut-être faut pas faire ça tu
peux pas
cher
c'est certain qu'on pratique
efficace
wah wah wah wah stouff
est-ce qu'on a des parties justement
dans le prague qui a joué à un coût qui
n'est pas bon
la puce 6
il ya des jeux tour des villes je dis
que c'est bon c'est sûr l'ordinateur
c'est facile vous pouvez leur dire
c'est facile quand on leur dit mais
apparemment apple sont déclarés tour a
eu de quitter
village bété dans le très logique et
c'est ça donc comme on dit beaucoup de
cases
fort parce que cavaler b3 et d'un
français 4 fausse la donne n'est pas
clair cinq tours invite ses cookies on
verra quelle logique là le roi droit que
j'adore 1010 à
18 gymnase terme des cinq dames des cinq
personnages assez forte
en manque d'un bébé sain qui pourrait
voir d'un v8
mais surprise je mange
et les coups de 8
mois g7 pour
18,8
me rentrer encore une attaque
intéressante et l'a donc les blancs
peuvent peut-être s'en sortir
d'après tour de rôle
à tanger
j'ai proposé à paris donc mary est ce
la plage ne décline pas ce que
c'est mais tu veux tu veux tu veux
parler quoi en fait il pense que si le
rapport est
à 8 ans mais je vais pas parié la partie
qui a gagné
contre
moi gagner enfin pour moi rapport lui
avais je vais je vais pas parié contre
on ne peut se faire avant déjà avec guy
ringo je vais parier sur la victoire
d'un rapport
si tu veut parier sur rapport dont paris
pas si tu veut parier sur la nulle ben
je suis ton amant
la pression alors encore
présager reste quatre coups à jouer pour
atteindre 2 40e jour que deux minutes
pour traquer et vite pour vite donc
c'est chaud
ce plan
va couper ton ordi a tué le matin
voisine où je vais enlever
enfin après franchement les coûts sont
introuvables injuste bon alors c'est le
gaf
bombes et quatre mois mais elle se
produit on la ressent que se voit juste
trop
on a sécurité ramadan le pion à quatre
c'est pas du tout un outil efficace et
la serre sont fidèles défenseurs ici la
police militaire
complète heures en fait ici là le coût
par les north gagne parce qu'il ya
portera à huit le coup qui l'a pas ratée
avant
mais sinon est aussi cavale et b3 callac
fort qu'ils avaient les baies 3 c'est
quoi l'idée avait approuvé deux pompiers
de forces est
sûrement bien donc t'as pas de coups
oui
qui réunit les trois robots de cavale et
ses seins qu'ils seront 1 3001 c'est pas
sûr qu'ils jouent autour invite s'il
appelle dès lors à
ce qu'un coup comme une tornade heure
par exemple
les
escrocs comme tourneur tout fait aussi
gagner
à ions
ce qu'avait délictueux que tu m'as
s'agit d'un revêtement pas du tout là je
vois clairement mémoire comptes sont là
pour le coup c'est une position gagnante
on croise un chantier de la salle papa
qui est juste je
fais comprendre qui est gagnant et
non mais par exemple la partie la partie
d'hier y compris si bien qu il y avait
une pièce pour trois pions c'est comme
pour moi en fait sans drôle mais pour
mme penchard a fondé apple sont à
prendre comme êtres étranges exemple
c'est bengo
ça va les arts visuels ment pas si
simple là où on voit comment que le fou
de me lecavalier leroy et passifs
j'ai cherché dans le pont pour attaquer
londres
et au 6ème d'avoir tant de avec d'un
match fut l'échec aussi se regardent
ils ont reparlé de de géométrie c'était
magnifique si on gagne on a mené la
tamoa suite de ces six ça serait très
bon moi je connais mon poulain me
connais comme tu l'avais fait
et
non
oui la défende il a peut-être amené sa
tombe et de attendant
ça paraît logique
j'ai l'impression
d'aller détroit quand même mais tu veux
tout cas de greffe 6 bois concis clair
dans cet
horrible incident vers cette position
mais en fait c'est pour ça que lui-même
que l'on attendait non plus hein oui
tant que simple un bandit mais en
pratique c'est très dur à défendre son
droit le roi est rodé ouais un peu ce
sujet par les noirs gigote de partout et
tu peux pas je trouve l'ordinateur peut
se tromper que
jamais paris
y a plus que deux minutes
faut qu'il arrive à
garder une position je vous regarde ses
40e et ça devrait aller
j'ai même les battre en
grand pour voir
caméras
n'ont soit pas encore
fait un petit délai chez moi once
d'énergie qui excède pas sûr que ce soit
que ça valait vraiment le coup c'est
vieux
mais je ne peux pas encore donc un peu
pâteuse puis la guerre ou gers touffe
non mais c'est là c'est le string est
toujours en cours
[Musique]
ah
je vois pas grand chose quand en plus on
va on va pas le temps
il fallait voir la la la la la vie
d'avant la position et la dame qui est
venu en b 4 aussi de mettre un bon coup
cas c'est logique
ça n'a
pas trouvé le lien
il faut que le serveur et là il a eu
jusqu'à l'argentine et qui rentre en
compte un
petit bébé quand même ça fait du chemin
waouh je suis aussi
après map a également bon il faut il
faut faire attention
au bonsaï ses prix en forte hausse si
triste ouf
oui
est-ce que tu auras tu t'étais pas plus
fort il y avait 3 2 en salle à
manger spirou il est ouvert à kolda est
ce qu il avait dit
qu'il a vu mais en même temps c'était
tellement dur sa position là partout
4 lappartient
rapport rapport à balancier g3
aussi
j'imagine tour est vite
bondée de hockey et tours à huit tours à
deux peut-être
le petit ouf
il y aura quatre blessés il y aura
peut-être cavale et c5 et sur tourcoing
8 d'un point à 8,3 b2g cavale et des
trois tours c'est bien je regarde ce qui
laissait 3 sûrement peut-être tour c'est
ainsi qu'il peut être une menace
attention au contre
projet
auquel tour s'est vite pour ses huîtres
est au coût pour atteindre
l'allemand salvateur ici pour les deux
hommes et qui vont pouvoir ensuite
réfléchir pas c'est surtout le practice
avoir besoin je pense du temps ça lui
fera du bien c'est une position gagnante
alors didonne seul coup d'un point à 4,4
des livres jeux la forteresse atteint
quasiment plus qu'un pour lui pour le pr
moi mais tu dois te prend 1,4
apparemment c'est la grosse fâcherie
sont très difficiles à prendre surtout
nous inquiète
je pense qu'il va pas le faire je pense
qu'il va
pas sauf si vraiment il ya vraiment une
raison en paille auquel cas la droite
une menace mais tu peux te dire oui j'ai
eu lieu quand j'ai pas tout va toujours
essayer dès
la 4e minute pour prendre sa décision
vitesse il va sûrement les utiliser
c très très chaud
allez c'est maintenant qu'on blender
j'avais un support pour aveyron
pas compris
c'est maintenant qu'on blender côtes
yéménites
donc fait un nom et son prénom
et sound of sound famille
c'est audrey la dame toi c'est tout faux
combat je pense pas
la tutelle est lui déjà c'est aussi de
battre deux contre un taxi noir compas
attention
le même dans un petit coin de ta tête et
espérons qu'en la gagner ici
bah si
mais si tu avec un point doit légalement
avec son faible ces gens là tu as tu
parles radâmes à la wii pour ça tu
d'accord d'accord ça prend un cache
ta aucune chance de gagner
mal compris ouais d'accord donc il y a
eu
pas eu
à la limite alors où est ta question
c'était à la place de bakel moment parce
que pour l'instant il n'a pas eu
l'occasion d'un précédemment habitants
mais il y a attaqué il y aurait 3 2 en
plus avec un clou tout âge sont en
cavale la dame attention
ferme est une tour en vis-à-vis
potentiellement à notre dame elle a fait
son travail le clouage aussi sur la
première rangée
et j'ai dit qui a joué fameux 7 sauf
qu'il n'a pas donnés la dame juive
single loser
a hélas hélas par contre on va à des
actifs ce combat doit se tordre et vite
je vais chercher un père pète mais là
maintenant ben on voit on vient de
contredire route davidts damas les oui
parce que dans mes bras route
en fait c'est que c'est un personnage
c'est que vu des tribunes lastours des
huit échecs ramel pour couvrir la
huitième rang j'ai hésité
éviter cet échec perpétuelle peut-être à
l'épreuve quand il s'est vu david joué
par prague beyrouth
qu'est-ce qu'il est fort a franchement
ça mérite bien un petit soft tout ça il
l'a jouée à 5 secondes à 5 soit meriem
des amériques le sol et on va montrer
stouff
je sais pas comment je passe moi aussi
je fais un coup d' attaque
et ont jeté de menaces émanent du coup
le perpétuel
on voit que sur cases noires seront ils
à pipe pas les semaines fait ici de
l'accord est la mise pour montrer qu'on
est obligé de
faire une nul ici c'est pour ça que il
était il mort diada les efforts dans la
8ème branger le temps en recréant des
menaces
il espère croiser sur 3,2 du coup
dépasser ce que j'ai demandé stouff à
tous me demande qu'est ce qui se passe
sur toi de pages nous pense que
peut-être au bout j'ai la table il ya pu
mal tourner vite jorat
comme ça moi je dirais adams et 6 à
tempo et je vois que la mer une tourbe
et bleu d'accord avec moi
je remets assez des bêtises la japd être
trouvé un moyen de
de mieux placé malades d'être malin par
commence alors son sur dame 6,6 sur un
ordinateur et du tour des deux dames à
midi
10 nuls
et du coup
il a changé d'âme des quatre dames de
voeux où il tourne le damany
l'adq l'espace et patrice loko times
c'est quoi
baisser avec
tranquille de chasse au petit gibier 5 y
stabiliser entre ge et cavaliers et puis
après l'ag damas il va jouer dans un jeu
par les vingt sept places et
donc on n'a plus qu'un pion de moyens de
récupérer déjà un enfant
et pas mal de d'initiative donc la très
très bonne nouvelle pour prague c'est
que leurs habitants par là ils viennent
de récupérer 50 minutes chacun et ils en
50 minutes pendant vingt coups
et on va et 20 coups après débat qu'ils
auront encore un quart d'heure de route
temps arrive toujours 30 secondes points
ou
wii route ces quartiers jeu parce que
bahia un club disponible entre le roi
noir il peut être faible aussi des fois
mais pour l'instant il est vrai que
c'est quand même plutôt les oies
blanches dans votre lit de la partition
pour défendre les pièces parfois de
tours l2 le club allait bien se sont
vraiment en défense
c'est que j'attends beaucoup plus siège
de problèmes blancs les noirs ils
auraient précis vinci ils vont pas
attention ils peuvent se prendre perpète
notamment mais déjà à priori un peu plus
la perdre normalement pas par hasard si
fenat c'est gros c'est rare mais
des cas dans une situation où les blancs
se battre pour leur survie
oui oui ça joue à deux résultats
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé donc se
touchait qu'un one rapporte
rien pas en arrière alors que le peu qui
s'est passé
et des joueurs aussi qui viennent de
terminer leur taille note est
d'atteindre le 40e
là j'ai vu qu'ici le bâtiment regarde ça
ne pouvait pas tout pour et blanc
et c'est moi quand même pas attendre aux
endroits alors de bain la réponse car je
peux rien faires j'attends
donc clairement amélioré notre position
avec les noirs
érigé
hockey dont il a défendu les pions sont
bien évidemment on voit pas jouer 3
parce qu'il ya un blocus sont cases
noires
et donc il faut faire tous haha je suis
là pour défendre le pion et après menacé
voir tellement de ne pas lancer des
plongées
cavaliers f4 et g3 acajou et
bien sûr je crois c'est trash 3h de
fougue 4 déloger la tourache ans s'est
terminée et faire une dame s'est trouvé
obligé de donner les cavaliers au
plateau ouais mais ce serait pas besoin
du coup il est quoi sur reims 3 / g iii
il a pas besoin de changer de
vie s'est bloquée sur 15 mois le pitch
inquiet mais fou au 4 octobre le cadre
bien sûr c'est la partie pour bouge et
h3 maintenant et c'est terminé
c'est terminé je menace quoi en fait la
menace quoi bon g20 un vieux problème ça
doit guérir
et à 3 wii peut rien faire avec les plus
intéressants à 2h en
date on ne peut pas bouger s'il
abandonne la seconde rangée on va manger
perdable le roi il veut pas se mettre en
travers et ne veut pas se rapprocher
est-ce que c'était excuses monatte
patoureaux b8
après lui mais du coup d'attendre est ce
que dans deux jours ça jouets de cour
des grands je prends à eux deux ils
estimaient alors est ce efficace le tube
adam
et du coup en plus après tour des huit
je veux tu manges pas je te fait froid
je te
maxime il ya deux trois échecs
je veux mettre mon
attention et c'est
bon tu touches la vue de faire apprendre
à
[Musique]
pêcher joli tour des butins c'est joli
c'est surtout valoir surtout qu'il a eu
sur ajoutant là est donc surtout rebouge
trois
menaces tour der vaart oui est si jeune
et si je prends maintenant
trois des huit attendait vraiment pas
bien
élevé et
oui et bien on met dans le vent pour
bien en force le roi semaine devant la
tour et la tour pourra pas empêcher
points 2
et sur quel c'est pareil voilà
ton prise et je croise deux objectifs
oui messieurs dames par
[Musique]
wave
combattante et jolies filles mais je
trouve bien joué ça va passer non non
bah ils proton temps rien à voir
directement ils ont de carbone haye doit
l'avoir vu aussi c'est normal du calcul
y verrait bien et fils et
ne pas accepter
oui l'homme est ce à ce qu'est une offre
malhonnête de sa part assure c'est là le
malhonnête
bon même si c'est que je suis jouer à
quelques frais à prendre n'importe quel
appareil mais là faut quand même pas
abuser
devrait avoir regardé les trois nuls
pour l'instant visite perdant avec les
blancs caruana perdant avec les blancs
doux beau perdant avec les blancs ça
pourrait être la journée
même si grand des lieux il va devoir
travailler et avant de filer en pause on
va peut-être aller voir plus tôt
marquant de rien en fait ouais ça vous
intéresse davantage parce que la
question arrivait au 40e coup aussi donc
c'est passé beaucoup de choses
ouais
s'est passé beaucoup de choses à romans
et essais
de chris foy 6 on a vu un tel accueil
sévère passive et au zizi que la
position
du petit prodige france était plutôt
prometteuse
donc il était venu là pour empêcher les
fourchettes
à 4 ans et continue son expansion
d'armes très logique
pour ces deux crises crise
il a ramené son fonds 17 mois ont libéré
sa tour j'imagine
pourchasse lecavalier l'harmonie via
aussi
où les blancs petites natures que
légèrement amélioré leur position et
vous réussirez installer un blu 40 des
cas
encore de quoi paniquer il ya du jeu par
rapport à sion
pas si le joueur néerlandais
battu
d'un rien
en attendant cette position
qui la contrôle de nos colonnes ouverte
mais bon ça reste solide a l'impression
que c'est dur pour les deux camps
vraiment progresser en fait un an
et ça peut être l'île de piot m'isoler
aussi parce que les espèces de statuts
comptes s'est
installée actifs
j'ai refusé la répétition
voilà ça
lui pendait
c'est vraiment un homme qui refuse
cette position et refuse
mais tombée trois ça peut quand même
faire nul encore méfiants 40e coup
maintenant et veut réfléchir après
souvent les les la pétition sont pas
forcément dire qu'on veut faire mieux
c'est aussi pour gagner du temps pour le
40e coup annoncé la fermeture des cartes
lorsque
je vois pas
ne pas repartir dette pour des
fourchettes
je peux pas me bouger avec
la découpe de tomber sa famille ensuite
trois mois je pense que la du lisible
sur le très probable
ce serait un très bon résultat pour
marc-andré avec les noirs qui validerait
sa salle du temps avec les blancs d'hier
ok stouff je crois qu'il est temps de
passer au pot d haguenau sont tous
terminés on va revenir ensuite avec la
meinau est quand même
4 partir dans le masters
pas mal d'animations aujourd'hui à
suivre après après la pause ouais
[Musique]
nous
à
[Musique]
oh
nous sommes de retour on cherche tous
vous reste car vous êtes toujours avec
nous et bon cette petite pause et borna
richard rapporte ya mis fin
dernier espoir de caruana
ouais donc évitons des huit comme
l'avait pronostiqué le groupe souffre
exactement le jeu
ouais ont tenté de jouer
avec cette menace de maths
mais le seul moyen de l'appareil ainsi
la kf2 pour le roi est derrière
filer à dame donc une victoire avec les
noirs pour caruana un second qui perd
avec les blancs même si la terre à
bruxelles avec les blondes déjà contre
thierry
nier deux parties de suite qu'un radar
j'avais l'impression qu'ils se soient
lancés et bat toujours pas il al'art
moyal il a du mal ça commence à faire
beaucoup pour l'ex numéro 2 mondial et
l'extérieur
n'at il pas trop embrouillé pas il est
pas très bon à prendre pendant ce temps
danse dans ce tournoi mais j'ai envie de
dire ça fait c'est la parano et demi
maintenant
abc
avoir cependant les prochains candidats
dans la résurrection du phénix à bientôt
on verra ça dans quelques mois en
espagne
du coup stouff et oui alex caractère
avec les blancs il a fait une gaffe en
fait
avoir changé on peut
la gare était beaucoup moins grosse la
confrérie lui avait coûté une tour
là il ya perdu un jour notre ami
s'interroge dans cette position
rapport venait d'attaquer longer 4 la
position est équilibrée intéressante
carney a voulu défendre latéralement
avec sa tour et il a oublié la petite
pointe
ici le fameux e5 intermédiaire
du coup la tour qui dépendraient le foot
doit partir
et des taxes comme moteur et donc saga
lampions alors après fait là encore la
convertir stouff
et à or même si la page est elle si le
tout meilleur coût
quand même livré une très belle
prestation ensuite
qui ont fait la décision
il est une sorte de sucre en contrebas
position là pour les blancs du coup j'ai
une pièce donc très belle victoire de
rapports
il à 1.40 scène donc on a guéri qui en
deuxième place avec ses ennemis et après
on a mamediarov rapport avec 6 points ça
y remonte à la troisième place ex-aequo
réchard rapport dont qu'il est
il a donc ainsi faire de ce tournoi
c'est lui reste à jouer doolow blanc
demain dubois qui
est au fond du trou et super entonnoir
et et d'un à partie avec les blancs
contre guiry donc aux trois adversaires
où il peut clairement marquer des points
ça va être dur de rattraper l'écart à
celle ci c'est
une partie mais en tout cas ils peuvent
peser que le podium et richard a pas
alors on va peut-être aller voir une
partie on a peu suivi moment pour faire
un endroit autre et c'était beau et bon
reste
oui
bon tout à l'heure je jouerai il y avait
des
souvent injustes ordinateur qui disait
que l'équipe enhco avait un avantage
enormissime hockey et je me suis
vraiment pencher dessus mais je
comprenais pas
position
n'était par ici on va voir ce qui s'est
passé il essaie de prendre de l'esba de
trouver du jeu à les dames avec les
noirs pourquoi pas
a écrit une attaque même si
ça fait pas si peur
c'est tout et c'est registre j'étais sur
un bateau
et maintenant balle est hors jeu en fait
alors je sais tout va
causer
des fuites en fait je pense que la tour
devait probable on est perdu peut-être
un bandeau avec un g4
je sais pas
tous rêvent 2
ce qui est un moyen de pouvoir c'est de
bouffer lattois
qu'avaient les f3 cas de
danger 6
c'est quoi
non mais en cadeau je comprends pas
pourquoi à l'ordinateur et donnant un
aussi grand athlète cavaliers à 49,5
intéressant à voir avoir moins recours à
voir avant qu'ils attaqueraient leçon d
ouais et soir fou prendre comprendre et
bunge et la case
quatre
ans
et qu'est ce qui se passe si je mens
juste des
6es du coup alors je trompe à mesure on
va on va traiter un petit peu pourquoi
les bons souliers en punch courbe qui
relève trois temps le 6 km à 10 h 14 et
5 6 4 6 4
ok juin coup hasard
- g
3g blouin council attends tu vas juste
tu resteras
si tu prends champions f et je note un
cadre
laïc
son avantage c'était quand même pas
évident on est tous les points noirs
ici
juste faire bref si ce mot on va changer
les tours effet retour est fluide mais
attention la fourchette
tour ff8
de la toux et avait déjà été plus bref
l'impression qui s'est créé
tout ça il s'est trouvé que ça tourne
mal placé
et voir ce qui s'est passé ensuite il
n'a pas forcément exploite au mieux mais
ce n'est pas évident d'avoir
été mangé des pions
j'attends ici a eu l'idée ça va être bon
ckac de récupérer pièce khartoum
et donc ça fait un tour de plus
ok sa femme non plus ne va pas voir la
galerie
d'amenée ya l'europe leur nom est un peu
plus faible
que jamais 5 et
ben je l'inclus bas c'est quoi
des médecins québécois la
g6 et
tourner si c'est peut-être pas si débile
pour le 6e tour ait eu deux
pros défend - le plus en danger
parce que
[Musique]
jean coutu va
trés genre je me revenir la tombe était
je sais pas
moi je tente immense ça devrait quand
même obtenir
faire attention donc au regret super
coach fait si souvent de far as tu
verras ce pouf verra ce que ça donne ça
pourrait durer cette partie
est monté lui cela qui m'a qui m'avait
il peut briller par son choix de vie
changer les donnes ça je m'en remets
toujours pas
pour le virus alors qu'ils n'avaient
d'être cédé aux demandes de partout du
bois que tu es prêt à tendre la main
pour abandonner
et ici ou là des joueurs ceux qui nous
rejoignent
montage mamour col de sa veste et
d'échangé raid arbre alors que ramé
cavaliers detroit
c'est un peu la boucherie cette position
images et objets de dire ça tu ne peux
pas d'autres
notre qualification pour ce choix de
ouais moi je comprends c'est parti à
technique intuit tu enlève tout le
contrôle jeu était sûr d'avoir davantage
sur long terme moi je crois je dis je
serai patte artistique je dirais
ça enlève les contres vieux était sûr
c'est sûr gagner dans un bas de soie sur
deux hommes et
[Musique]
femmes et a promu talent a pendu à une
position qui peut se retourner si jamais
tu attaques pas bien je peux comprendre
sa décision
mais non mais je suis d'accord que
j'aurais pas fait ça mais je peux
comprendre
est déjà sortie de crise est liée pour
le goûter est-ce qu'ils pourrissent les
petits côtés du boeuf
qui s'est alors du coup comment ça qu'on
fait cette saison comme je voulais pas
vrai depuis ce temps d'avancé sur les
autres c'est arrivé plus tôt un point du
40e
ouais
tu dis que ça doit peut-être la game est
passionnel quoi ce qu'il peut y avoir à
tout le monde que tu vas devoir ramener
trois par là il pourrait y avoir du coup
le jeu d'une façon ou d'une autre ici où
les blancs de cet espace sur les pions
en bois
clair du tout cette position évidemment
tu joues pour le garder
ses joueurs d'être sûr de rien gagné
pour moi
garde répétées
moi c'est trois mois ces trois gaffe par
la
caf
donc qui va vous respirez du poids après
cette coupe en ensemble
ouais après ces quatre c'est pas si
facile à jouer mais de donner de plus on
peut essayer même si tu est active je
pense qu'ici ils auraient dû rentrer
dans la finale deux tours dont ce qu'on
a fait son cavalier lesquels dominent et
claude est beaucoup plus dangereuse
parce que ce que tu en penses
mais il faut les cauchemars et dans tmh
dans cette finale robin voilà auquel tu
vas devoir cette fonction tu vas garder
pour moi mais je suis à voir mais contre
choses par là
et je suis sur mon pardon mais ok va
falloir qu'ils soient précis pour maman
qui l'a pas fait ça
et l'appréhender cas
alors pourquoi c'est si grave le stuff
est ce qu'il ya un problème sur ce plan
là vraiment bon en fait j'attaque le
pion et ses petits défauts avec
cavalaire 3 km avec 3g pour sa 4 qui
change de pièce
il est vraiment en mode il est écouté en
fait de salariés de sa partie
qu'il est petit est double il à 1h12
entre 10 minutes et ciotti
je pense qu'il est avant tout un
cavalier sais c'est qu'au lieu de
prendre
zhu min
alors je crois que les permis miniers ou
me semble que je le connais
est ce que par hasard je vais me tuer
est-ce que par appeler pas niçois
se peut que me parle grandement
ses sacs
et ses cartes et chèques ça c'est sûr
ouais
aux guitares sur rien alors que son
homologue
vivarais
mois
à venir nous saluer ta l'emblème plaisir
que tu as regarda ce stream
n'hésite pas à participer et à des
questions de suggestions
et xavier d'un concerto pour tenir ce
genre jordan je l'avais découvert face
dans une école dans laquelle je donne